चलिए सो आई थिंक वी आर
लाइव वी आर
लाइव हेलो हेलो हेलो एवरी बडी मेरी आवाज
जा रही है सबको आम ऑडिबल विजिबल क्लियर सब
कुछ क्लियर है जरा मुझे कंफर्म कर दीजिए
आप लोग और जल्दी से जवाइन कर लीजिए सभी
लोग सभी लोग जल्दी से जवाइन कर लीजिए एंड
प्लीज कंफर्म मी
ऑडियो वीडियो एवरीथिंग फाइन एंड वेट करते
हैं सभी लोगों को जवाइन करने देते हैं
हेलो आरटेक आयुष निशान तान्या वल्लव क्या
हालचाल रितिक लो जेंस आयुष
रितेश चलो आज आने देते हैं 100 लोगों को
100 लोगों को आ जाने देते
पहले ठीक है आज की बहुत धमाकेदार क्लास है
धमाकेदार टॉपिक है बहुत शानदार हम टॉपिक
लेकर आए हैं बहुत कुछ करने वाले हैं आज की
क्लास में ठीक है
ठीक है ठीक है चलिए बढ़िया
बढ़िया
ओके नमस्कार भाई सभी लोगों को
एंड नमस्कार
नमस्कार चलो अभी सभी लोग आ जाओ यार जल्दी
से जल्दी से बुला लो सभी को बाकी जो है
बचे हुए सबको बुला लो फटाफट बुला लो जल्दी
से बुला
लो वीडियो प्राइवेट नहीं कीजिएगा ठीक है
ओके हेलो सर ग्रेट सर ऑसम मास्टर थैंक यू
थैंक यू ब्रदर थैंक यू थैंक यू सो
मच यू कैन सी दिस वीडियो यस यस यस यू कैन
सी अलग टॉपिक है आप देख सकते हो कोई
दिक्कत कोई दिक्कत नहीं है कोई दिक्कत
नहीं है देख सकते हो
चलो जब तक 100 लोग आ रहे हैं तब तक कुछ
चीजें बता देता हूं यहां पे एज यूजुअल यह
हमारा
linkedinsign.com 850 से भी ज्यादा मेंबर
फिलहाल है उसको जवाइन कर लीजिएगा जो कि एक
हमारी कम्युनिटी है एंड वहां पे आप चीजों
को सीख सकते हैं शेयर कर सकते हैं एक
दूसरे के साथ सब कुछ कर सकते हैं ठीक
है प्रेजेंट प्रेजेंट
प्रेजेंट ओके चलिए चलिए तो आज तो यार आज
काफी लोग आ गए हैं बढ़िया अच्छी बात है
चलिए काफी लोग आ रहे हैं ट्स ग्रेट देखो
मैं बोलता हूं इसलिए क्योंकि आपका फायदा
है आपका बेनिफिट है याद रखिएगा जो मैं
बुलाता हूं आप लोगों को इट्स योर बेनिफिट
गाइस वो बेनिफिट अगर नहीं लोगे तो फिर
कैसे काम चलेगा यह भी तो सोचो वह बेनिफिट
नहीं लोगे तो कैसे काम चलेगा जस्ट थिंक
अबाउट इट
राइट आपके बेनिफिट के लिए बोला जाए और वोह
ना करोगे तो कैसे चलेगा आज हम करने वाले
हैं एचटीएमएल इंजेक्शन ठीक है अभी मैं
आपको बताने वाला हूं एचटीएमएल इंजेक्शन के
बारे में क्या है यह क्या कर सकता है यह
और किस तरीके का कितना डेंजरस हो सकता है
यह एंड यह एबिलिटी बहुत ही बहुत इजली आपको
मिल सकती है वेब एप्लीकेशंस में ठीक है तो
इसके बारे में हम जानेंगे समझेंगे सब कुछ
अभी तक सिर्फ 64 लोग ही आए हुए हैं ओनली
64 आर
देयर मैं देखता हूं यहां
पे
ओके यहां पे 40 मोर रिक्वायर्ड 40 अ
अटें मोर रिक्वायर्ड यह मैंने लिख
दिया चलिए कर
दिया लेट एवरी बडी
जवाइन 80 लोग आ चुके हैं बहुत बढ़िया वेरी
गुड वेरी गुड यह हुई ना बात यार यही तो
चाहिए यही तो बोल रहा था कि आप लोग आओ ना
आप लोग अगर आओगे लाइव में आओगे लाइव में
अपने दर् दोगे और मैं आपको फिर क्वालिटी
कंटेंट ना दूं तब बोलना कि
सर क्वालिटी कंटेंट आप नहीं दे रहे हम
लाइव में आ रहे हैं फिर भी इस तरीके से या
हम जॉइन कर रहे हैं हम अपनी प्रेजेंस दिखा
रहे हैं तब भी आप नहीं दे रहे हो तब तब तो
बोलना यार सर आपके में गलती है यहां तो
तुम लोग नहीं आते तुम लोग के लिए इतना
जबरदस्ती मुझे करना पड़ता है और सेशन तक
मुझे वो करना पड़ता है यह तो अच्छी बात
नहीं है सोचो ना तुम जस्ट इमेजिन करो यार
तुम्हें प्रो बग बाउंट हंटर बनना है अभी
जो टॉपिक्स चल रहे हैं इंडिपेंडेंट
टॉपिक्स है इनका पिछले टॉपिक से कोई लेना
देना नहीं है आज के भी टॉपिक का पिछले
टॉपिक से कोई लेना देना नहीं है यह बात
याद रखिएगा तो आपको एक हंटर बनना है बग
हंटिंग करना है अच्छे लेवल प और आपको फ्री
में एक प्रीमियम कंटेंट मिल रहा है जो लोग
कोर्सेस में बताते हैं जनरली सच बता रहा
हूं उसके आप 5000 10000
देंगे उसकी क्लासेस लेंगे पैसे देके आप
क्लासेस लेंगे बट यहां फ्री में आपको मिल
रहा है तो आप नहीं ले रहे तो इसमें क्या
करेगा कोई बताओ अब किसी आपके पेरेंट से
बात हो रही होती तो मैं पेरेंट से बात कर
लेता आपको बट इतने पॉसिबल नहीं है ना इतने
लोगों के पेरेंट्स से बात करना उनको बोलना
फोर्स क्या करना जब आपको खुद की चिंता
नहीं है तो खुद की चिंता कीजिए ना बस यार
सीखो इसी में डूब जाओ बग हंटिंग तभी कर
सकते हो तभी तुम प्रो बनोगे जब तुम इसमें
डूब जाओगे याद रखिएगा बग बाउंट इज नथिंग
बट टू अ इमर्स योरसेल्फ इनसाइड दैट इनसाइड
दिस पर्टिकुलर डोमेन जब तक आपकी वो इमर्शन
नहीं होगी तब तक फिर गड़बड़ है याद रखिएगा
ठीक है यह होनी चाहिए इमर्शन आपकी तो आज
जो हम एटीएम इंजेक्शन करने वाले हैं इसको
ना लोग सिमिलर
टू सिमिलर टू एक्सेसेस भी बोलते हैं क्रॉस
क्रॉस साइट स्क्रिप्टिंग इसको बोलते हैं
बट यह होता एक्सेसेस नहीं है लेकिन
क्योंकि एचटीएमएल इंजेक्शन को एक जनरल बात
अगर जनरल तरीके से देखे तो हम उसको चेन अप
कर सकते हैं टू एक्सेसेस अब मान लो नॉर्मल
एचटीएम इंजेक्शन
पे आपको बाउंट लग रही है $50 की तो जब
आफ्टर चेन कर दोगे ना आफ्टर चेनिंग टू
एक्सेसेस तो यह आपको $500 तक भी मिल सकती
है इससे ऊपर भी आपको बाउंट मिल सकती है
क्या बात है 97 लोग आ चुके हैं ं आज तो
यार तुम लोगों ने कमाल कर दिया यह दिल खुश
करने वाली बात हो गई बताओ 100 हो ही
जाएंगे मुझे पता है बट वेरी वेरी थैंक यू
बहुत मजा आ रहा है यह देख के कि आप लोग 97
पीपल आर हियर करेंटली एंड ट्स ग्रेट एवरी
बडी चलो कुछ तो समझ में आया आप लोगों को
चलो कुछ तो समझ में आया 97 लोग आ चुके 100
भी हो जाएंगे मुझे पता
है कोई बात नहीं चलो कोई बात नहीं 100 भी
आ जाएंगे थैंक यू थैंक यू एवरी बडी फॉर
जॉइनिंग चलिए तो जब एटीएम इंजेक्शन करोगे
तो $ और एटीएमएल को चें कर दोगे एक्सेसेस
में तो अप्रॉक्स मान के चलो 00 0000 लर
000 डिपेंड करता है इंपैक्ट क्या है आपका
अब एटीए इंजेक्शन का मतलब क्या होता है
पहले उसको हम समझते हैं सिंपल सा समझते
हैं सिंपल सा देखो बहुत ही सिंपल सा इसका
मतलब है बहुत ही प्यारा सा सिंपल सा मतलब
है क्या मैं आपको एक वेबसाइट पे विजिट
कराता हूं मैं इस पे लेके चलता हूं आपको
टेस्ट पीएचपी पे ठीक है एटीएमएल इंजेक्शन
यानी कि आप कोई एटीएमएल का टैग एटीएमएल
कोड इंजेक्ट कर रहे हो किसी वेब एप्लीकेशन
में और वो आपका वेब एप्लीकेशन पास करके
आपको शो कर रहा है आपको वो सिंपली
एग्जीक्यूट कर रहा है दिखा रहा है
दैट्ची में आता हूं मैं एक सिंपल सा
एचटीएमएल टैग उठाता हूं सबसे सिंपल
एटीएमएल टैग क्या होगा h1 हेडिंग या
एचआरएफ लगा दो कोई लिंक डाल दो ठीक है
सिंपल से सिंपल टाइटल बॉडी कुछ भी कुछ भी
टैग चलेगा पहले हम h1 वाली टैग देखते हैं
तो हम एक सिंपल सा एचटीएमएल कोड लिखते हैं
जिसको हम बोलते हैं क्या लिखते हैं सिंपल
सा h1 हेडिंग के लिए यूज में लिया जाता है
इस एल टैग को हेडिंग के लिए h1 और यहां पे
लिखते हैं
सब्सक्राइब टू डेनिक्स अकेडमी
और h1 को हमने क्लोज कर दिया इस टैग को
क्लोज कर दिया अब ये हम कॉपी करते हैं और
इसको हम सिंपली यहां पे सर्च में डाल के
गो पे क्लिक करते हैं जैसे ही हमने गो पे
क्लिक किया यहां पे सब्सक्राइब टू डिक्स
अकेडमी आ गया अब ये h1 में आया हुआ है
यानी थोड़ा बोल्ड में थोड़े बड़े से लेटर
में आया है ओहो क्या बात है भाई 103
अटेंडेंस यर 103
अटेंडेंस
यहां मैं यहां पर एक बार यह कर देता
हूं जस्ट वेट अपडेट कर देता हूं आप लोगों
को 102 102 यहां पर लाइव आ चुके हैं मैं य
पर आपके उसमें डाल देता हूं ट चैनल
पर ग्रेट यह हुई बात यार यह यही तो बात
होती है यही तो तुम लोग दिल खुश कर दिया
तुम लोगों ने सच में
यह मजा आ रहा है अब मुझे भी मजा आ रहा है
ना बात यह
है चलिए चलिए तो मैंने डाल दिया पोस्ट कर
दिया प अब चलिए आ जाइए यहां पे अब यहां पर
हमने अगर मैं सिंपल सा इसको लिखता ना
सिंपल सा कैसे मैं अगर h1 नहीं लिखता देखो
मैं यहां पे सीधा लिख रहा हूं सब्सक्राइब
टू डिफन अकेडमी
मैं यहां पे सीधा सब्सक्राइब टू डिफन
अकेडमी सर्च कर रहा हूं तो यहां पे क्या आ
रहा है सिंपल सा ये क्वेरी एक जो हमने
क्वेरी रन की यहां पे वो प्रिंट होके आ गई
जैसे ही हमने टैग डाला यहां पे h1 के साथ
में ये बोल्ड हेडिंग के फॉर्म में आपके
सामने आ यहां पे
एटीएमएल यहां एटीएमएल इंजेक्शन पॉसिबल है
नाउ दिस इज एचटीएमएल इंजेक्शन एज सिंपल एज
दैट अब इसी तरीके से एक
html4 टैग होता है ठीक है तो w3 स्कूल्स
पे आप एचटीएमएल के बारे में पढ़ सकते हैं
बिल्कुल फ्री ऑफ कॉस्ट मस्त पढ़ाता है ये
तो यहां पे एक आई फ्रेम करके टैग है ठीक
है कुछ इस तरीके से एक आई फ्रेम करके टैग
है मान लो कोई सा भी एक ले लो कुछ भी ले
लो लाइक एग्जांपल मैं ये ले लो या कोई एक
यूआरएल टाइटल कुछ भी ले लो ना इसको ले लो
हमने यहां पे डाला यहां पे गो किया तो
यहां पे अब एक आई फ्रेम बनके आ चुका एक
देखो ये फ्रेम बनके आ गया 404 नॉट फाउंड
का क्योंकि हमने क्या डाला था कुछ इस
तरीके से डाला था एंड यहां हमने इसमें
कंटेंट में कुछ नहीं दिया था अंदर में
यहां पे सिंपल सोर्स जो है यूआरएल एक दे
दिया था एंड यहां पे टाइटल में अब यहां पे
यूआरएल में आपको मैं डाल देता हूं
https.com ये डाला हमने एंड यहां पे गो पे
क्लिक कर देते हैं ठीक है और लेट्स वेट गो
पे क्लिक किया जैसे ही गो पे मैंने क्लिक
किया यहां इस आई फ्रेम के अंदर में नक् क
वेबसाइट जो है ना वो पूरी की पूरी लोड हो
गई पूरी वेबसाइट लोड हो गई सिंपल सा फंडा
है मतलब हमने क्या किया यहां हमने आई
फ्रेम का एक टैग उठाया यह कुछ इस तरीके का
टैग उठाया यहां यूआरएल में रिप्लेस कर
दिया इसे हम अपने जो भी हमारा टारगेट
यूआरएल है तो आप evil.com कर सकते हैं
evil.com क्या है बेसिकली टेस्टिंग के लिए
लोग रिफ्लेक्ट करा देते हैं evil.com को
तो evil.com पे जब आप जाएंगे तो यह एक
टेस्टिंग वेबसाइट है सिंपल सा फंडा है
evil.com वीी आर गोइंग टू evil.com तो
यहां पे आप इसको यूआरएल के तौर पे एक
मलेशियन वेक्टर के तौर पे इसको यूज़ कर
सकते हैं जब भी जहां पे यूआरएल देना हो
ठीक है मान लो आपकी वेबसाइट नहीं है तो
ठीक है फिलहाल हम डेनिक्स को यूज़ कर रहा
हैं हमने एल को भी यूज़ कर सकते हैं आपकी
मर्जी है कोई से भी यूआरएल यूज़ कीजिए तो
हमने यहां पे evil.com दे दिया अब हम यहां
पे आई फ्रेम वाली इस टैग को कॉपी कर लेते
हैं और अगर वेबसाइट पे हमारी एटीएमएल
इंजेक्शन है तो हमने जैसे ही डाला गो पे
क्लिक किया हमारी पूरी की पूरी यहां पे
वेबसाइट जो है इस फ्रेम के अंदर में लोड
हो चुकी है यानी कि यहां पे एटीएमएल
इंजेक्शन है नाउ यू कैन रिपोर्ट दिस
फाइंड करने का गेट प गेट पैरामीटर है कोई
उस पे ट्राई कर सकते हो गेथ मेथड में है
कोई यूआरएल आप ओपन करो पोस्ट पे आप फाइंड
कर सकते हो कोई सा भी गेट या पोस्ट दोनों
पे आप फाइंड कर सकते हो आपको चाहिए एक
पैरामीटर अब पैरामीटर का मैंने क्या बताया
हुआ है आपको ऑलरेडी आपको पता ही होगा
पैरामीटर के बारे में सिंपल पैरामीटर का
मतलब क्या होता है
भाई क्या है fix.com स् क् मार्क यहां पे
आईडी इ पैराम पैराम ये पैरामीटर हो गया यह
जो चीज है यहां पे ये पैरामीटर की वैल्यू
हो गई आईडी एक पैरामीटर हो गई और इसकी
वैल्यू पैरम हो गई या आईडी = ट 1 दे दो
आपकी मर्जी है वो जो भी करो ठीक है तो
आईडी बिकम अ पैरामीटर एंड ये इसकी वैल्यू
हो गई अब ये पैरामीटर आपको चाहिए अब इसके
लिए आपको वेबसाइट को क्रॉल करना है हर एक
पैरामीटर पे एचटीएमएल को घुसा देना है
देखना है रिस्पांस में रिजल्ट रिफ्लेक्ट
हो रहा है कि नहीं हो रहा है
एचटीएमएल एग्जीक्यूट हो रही है कि नहीं हो
रही एग्जीक्यूट हो रहा है तो आप वेल डन
वेरी गुड गुड टू गो एंड आप आगे जा सकते
हैं अगर नहीं हो रहा है फिर थोड़ी सी फिर
वहां पर दिक्कत है अब यहां पर क्या कर
सकते हैं एक चीज में हमने यहां पर सिंपल
सा एक क्या दिया हमने यहां पे टैग दिया
सिंपल सा यहां पे ऐड आ गई है मैं इसको
स्किप कर देता हूं हमने यहां पे सिंपल
एचटीएमएल एक टैग दिया यहां पे हमने एसआरसी
आईम आई फ्रेम एसआरसी यहां पे हमने एक
यूआरएल दे दिया एंड यहां पे टाइटल
डिस्क्रिप्शन वगैरह ऐड कर दिया ठीक है बस
सिंपल सा अब यहां पे आप एक्सेसेस के पेलोड
भी डाल सकते हैं इट पॉसिबल टू इंजेक्ट
एक्सेसेस पेलोड
डायरेक्टली अगर वो एग्जीक्यूट होता है तो
वहां एक्सेसेस भी एग्जीक्यूट हो रहा है
सिंपल सा फंडा है बहुत सिंपल सा फंडा है
ठीक है
दैट्ची हो गई सिंपल सा अब हम क्या करते
हैं हम एक अ कोई भी एक सिंपल सा टार्गेट
चूज करते हैं एंड उसपे ट्राई आउट करते हैं
बट उसके पहले थोड़ा हम समझते हैं एक और
चीज को एटीएमएल इंजेक्शन के अंदर में जैसे
कि मैं एक लैब को ओपन कर रहा हूं आपके
सामने लैब कौन सा बवप जी हां बवप ठीक है
इसको हम ओपन करने वाले हैं बवप के लिए
आपको आप डायरेक्ट बवप इंस्टॉल कर सकते हैं
अपने विंडोज मशीन पे डायरेक्टली आप इसका
ट्यूटोरियल देख सकते हैं इंटरनेट पे मिल
जाएगा या तो आप सिंपल क्या कर सकते हैं
अपने वर्चुअल मशीन में यह रही वर्चुअल
मशीन अ ओके यह रही मेरी वर्चुअल मशीन
इसमें मैंने यह डाल रखा है ओ का ब्रोकन
वेब ए एप्लीकेशंस जितने भी ओ ब्रोकन वेब
एप्लीकेशंस है सारी इसके अंदर इंक्लूड की
गई है इसमें बी वेब भी है डीवीडब्ल्यू भी
है सब कुछ है तो आप इसको इसका सिंपल सा
आता है आपके पास इंस्टॉलेशन जिप फाइल आएगी
उसको ओपन कीजिएगा वीएम वेर की फाइल होगी
आप डायरेक्ट यहां पे इसको ओपन कर सकते हैं
मैं इसको पावर ऑन कर देता हूं एक बार ठीक
है
चलिए लेट्स
सी यह ऑन हो रहा
है क्या बात है भाई आज तो मजा आ गया यार
ऐसे तुम लोग सच बता रहे हो अगर ऐसे ही
तुमने अटेंडेंस और प्रेजेंस रखी ना हर
लाइव सेशन में सच बता रहा हूं हर लाइव
सेशन में मैं मतलब मजा आ जाए देखो क्या
होता है मैं सच बता रहा हूं एक चीज मैं
बताता हूं अभी बताओ
देखो साउंड धीरे है नहीं यार साउंड तो सही
है क्लियर ऑडियो है प्लीज चेक एट योर एंड
यस यस यस तुमने देखो तुम आ रहे हो तुम यार
लाइव सेशन चलाक अगर तुम मान लो बिजी हो या
किसी काम में हो तुम लाइ सेशन चला के छोड़
दो बस सिंपल सा फंडा है चला के तुम अपने
मोबाइल पर छोड़ो और अगर तुम बिजी हो तो
तुम अपना काम भी करो लेकिन नंबर्स जब यहां
दिखते हैं ना नंबर्स मैं सच सच बता रहा
हूं जो नंबर जैसे अभी जैसे मान लो 50 दिखे
और वहां 100 दिखे तो नंबर्स से अंदर से
आती है चीज कि अरे यार इतने बंदे हैं तो
उस चक्कर में इंसान और ज्यादा इनकरेजमेंट
उसके अंदर आती है इनकरेज होकर मजा मजे से
पढ़ाता है समझ में आ रहा है बस ट्स
इट ट्स इट गट इट एचटीएमएल इंजेक्शन का
सिंगल कुछ खास इंपैक्ट नहीं होता है उसको
आप चेन अप करेंगे एंड चेन अप करेंगे
मोस्टली इन एक्सेसेस क्रॉस साइट
स्क्रिप्टिंग एंड एक दो और चीजें हैं जो
मैं आपको अभी बताऊंगा आपको दिखेगी कि क्या
कर सकते हैं एटीएल इंजेक्शन से तो हमने ओ
को यहां पे चला दिया है एंड ये जो हमारे
इस पाथ पे है इस वाले यूआरएल पे 192168
2986 पे तो हम इसको ओपन कर लेते हैं
192.168
29.8 तो यहां पे ओ चालू हो चुका है ओ बड
यहां पे हम बी वप को ओपन कर लेते हैं वी
आर ओपनिंग बवप अब यहां पे बवप का लॉगइन
मांगेगा बवप का लॉगिन जो होता है लॉगिन
यूजर नेम होता है बी एंड पासवर्ड बग होता
है बी बग लॉग इन करते हैं य हम लॉगइन हो
चुके
हैं अब जिस बग
को सॉरी अभी हम लाइव लाइव हंट भी करेंगे
लाइव टारगेट को भी चूज करने वाले जिस बाग
को चूज करना है चूज कीजिए तो हम यहां
एसटीएल इंजेक्शन रिफ्लेक्टेड गेट वाला यूज
कर लेते हैं हम यहां पे गेट ये यूज कर हैं
अब मैं सारे तो सॉल्व नहीं करूंगा बट मैं
आपको जस्ट एक ओवरव्यू दे देता हूं ठीक है
तो यहां पे हमने दिया और इसका सिक्योरिटी
लेवल हम फिलहाल लो पे ही रखते हैं लो एंड
सेट करंट लो है ही हैक पे क्लिक कर देते
हैं हैक पे क्लिक किया यहां पे हमने
दैट्ची करने के लिए हम क्या करते हैं हम
क्या करते हैं हम इनपुट देते हैं
पैरामीटर्स पे यहां पैरामीटर क्या है
फर्स्ट नेम लास्ट नेम ये दो पैरामीटर्स है
हम यहां पे इनपुट देंगे ठीक है सिंपल एज
सिंपल एज दैट
अब देखो यहां इनपुट जब देंगे तो मैं पहला
इनपुट यहां पर दे देता
हूं हेलो दूसरा इनपुट देता हूं स्पाइडी
स्पाइडी गो प क्लिक करते हैं अगर यह इनपुट
आपके रिस्पांस में रिफ्लेक्ट हो रहा है
वहां एटीएल इंजेक्शन होने के चांसेस है
बिल्कुल तो यहां पर भी रिफ्लेक्ट हो रहा
है भाई वेल डन अब हम एटीएल इंजेक्शन को
चेक करेंगे तो अब हम उसके लिए क्या करेंगे
हम एटील इंजेक्शन का एक सिंपल सा h1 टैग
यहां पे दे देते हैं तो यहां हमने दिया h1
डि फ्रक्स एंड यहां पर लास्ट नेम में हमने
दे दिया यहां पे डिफो नहीं करते यहां
पे चलो डि फ्रक्स कर देते हैं यहां पर हम
कर देते हैं
h1
स्पाइडी दो चीज हमने दी डे फोनिक्स h1 और
स्पाइडी h1 अब यहां प हम गो पर क्लिक कर
देते हैं जैसे ही गो पर क्लिक करेंगे
हमारा डि फ्रक्स जो है यह भी h1 में
रिफ्लेक्ट हो रहा है स्पाइडी भी h1 में
रिफ्लेक्ट हो रहा है यानी हमारा काम यहां
हो गया यानी हमने पहला लेवल कर लिया ये
हेडिंग आ रहा है हेडिंग में आ रहा है यहां
पे रिफ्लेक्शन हो रही है यहां पे एमल
इजेक्शन है तो यहां हमने लो वाली
सिक्योरिटी लेवल को हमने कवर कर लिया एंड
दैट्ची
स्पाइडी ठीक है अब हम यहां पर गो प क्लिक
कर देते हैं अगेन डिफ्रॉक स्पाइडी हमारा
रिफ्लेक्ट हो रहा है अब हम सेम फिर से वही
चीज करते हैं h1 डि फ्रक्स एंड h1 स्पाइडी
एंड यहां पे गो पे क्लिक कर देते हैं अब
जैसे ही हमने गो पे क्लिक किया यहां अब यह
पूरा का पूरा h1 टैग ही रिफ्लेक्ट हो जा
रहा है यहां पे ये एग्जीक्यूट एज अ टैग एज
अ कमांड एग्जीक्यूट नहीं हो रहा एज अ
एचटीएमएल एग्जीक्यूट नहीं हो रहा ये एज अ
सिंपल स्ट्रिंग एग्जीक्यूट हो जा रही है
डि फोनिक्स स्पाइडी भैया क्यों हुआ तो
चलिए देखते खोजते हैं सोर्स सोर्स ओपन
करते हैं राइट क्लिक व्यू पेज सोर्स इसमें
देखते हैं हमारा स्पाइडी कहां पे
रिफ्लेक्ट हो रहा है ये देखिए ये देखिए
स्पाइडी और ये डि फ्रक्स इसको मैं थोड़ा
सा जूम इन कर देता हूं ताकि आपको दिख जाए
यहां पे ऐड को मैं वो कर देता हूं अब यहां
पे स्पाइडी रिफ्लेक्ट हो रही है डि फ्रक्स
बट यहां पे ये सैनिटाइज हो रहा है आप सब
देख सकते हैं ये
ट्रंकेट्स करने के लिए हम अलग-अलग तरह के
बायपासेस यूज कर सकते हैं क्या बायपासेस
हम इनकोडिंग कर सकते हैं यूआरएल इनकोडिंग
जिसको बोलते हैं वो कर सकते हैं हम ठीक है
तो पहले हम यूआरएल इनकोडिंग करके एक बार
देख लेते हैं तो हम क्या करते हैं सेम h1
डि फोनिक्स ये वाला जो टैग है इसको कॉपी
करते हैं बॉब शूट को ओपन कर लेते हैं
लेट्स ओपन बॉब शूट बब शूट से ही इनकोडिंग
कर लेंगे आप ऑनलाइन इनकोडिंग डिकोडिंग भी
यूज कर सकते हैं ऑनलाइन इनकोडर डिकोडर आता
है यूआरएल इनकोडर यूआरएल इनकोडर डिकोडर
सर्च कीजिएगा
सेट्स मिल जाएंगी वहां पे आप इनकोड डिकोड
कर सकते हैं बट हम यहां पे बब शूट का इन
बिल्ट इनकोडर डिकोडर यूज़ करने वाले हैं
ताकि आपको इसका भी आईडिया लगे कि एक्चुअली
ये कैसे काम करता है ठीक है तो हर एक चीज
की जानकारी होनी चाहिए डिकोडर पे चलते हैं
यहां पे क्योंकि ये हमें इनकोड करना है तो
हमने यहां पे टैग डाल दिया h1 डेनिक्स h1
ये डाल
दिया अब हमें इसको इनकोड करना है इनकोड एज
क्या करना है यूआरएल यूआरएल इनकोडिंग करनी
है तो हमने यूआरएल पे क्लिक किया इनकोडेड
वैल्यू यहां पे आ चुकी है ठीक है हम इसको
कॉपी कर लेते देते हैं चलिए हमने कॉपी
किया एंड वी पुट इट डाउन हियर इनकोडेड चीज
अब यहां पे लास्ट नेम में हमने लास्ट वाला
h1 वाला स्पाइडी वाला भी कॉपी कर लिया
इसको भी इनकोड करेंगे बर्ब शूट को ओपन
किया यहां पे इसको हटा दिया जो पहले वाला
हमारा टर्म था हमने स्पाइडी वाली डाल दी
इसको अगेन इनकोड एज यूआरएल कर देते हैं
इनकोड किया हमने एंड यहां इनकोडेड जो
स्ट्रिंग है उसको जो भी है यहां पे रिजल्ट
कॉपी कर पेस्ट कर दिया अब हम इसको क्या
करते हैं गो पे क्लिक करते हैं लेट्स सी
इट इज बायपासिंग र नॉट तो जैसे ही हमने गो
पे क्लिक किया इट्स बायपास एंड वी आर हियर
डि फ्रक्स स्पाइडी ठीक है तो हमें यहां पे
क्या मिल गया हमें यहां पे मिल गया
कंट्रोल य पे करते हैं कंट्रोल एफ करके
वेलकम सर्च कर लेते हैं तो यहां वेलकम
एंटर कर देते हैं कहां गया भाई वेलकम ये
रहा तो देखा आपने वेलकम यहां पे एंड यहां
पे h1 में डेनिक्स आ गया एंड h1 में यहां
पे स्पाइडी आ गई एंड ये हमारा एग्जीक्यूट
हो रहा है एज एटीएमएल गॉट इट ये समझ में आ
रहा है तो यहां पे हमने सेकंड लेवल भी
क्रॉस कर लिया इतना समझ में आ रहा है आप
लोगों को एवरीवन गेटिंग दिस प्लीज लेट मी
नो
प्लीज लेट मी नो
गाइस जल्दी बताइए
जल्दी थैंक यू मोहम्मद
फुरकान एवरीवन गेटिंग प्लीज प्लीज सभी लोग
रिप्लाई किए जल्दी से जल्दी
से
ओके अरे रिप्लाई तो मारो यार रिप्लाई तो
मारो रिप्लाई कर दिया करो यार रिपलाई नहीं
करते तुम लोग
यार पता तुम लोग बच्चों जैसे करते हो मुझे
जहां तक लगता है मतलब जब तक बोलो ना जब तक
जबरदस्ती ना करो तब तक काम ही नहीं होता
कोई यह यह क्या सिस्टम है यार
सोचो ठीक है चलो यह तो हो गया ठीक है तो य
हमने मीडियम मीडियम पर यहां पर सेट किया
है मीडियम पर हमने ये चीज की है अब हम य
पर हाई वाला भी ट्राई करेंगे हाई वाला ये
एस होमवर्क रखिएगा बट मैं आपको इसका थोड़ा
सा हिंट दे देता हूं हाई वाले का ठीक है
चलिए हमने हाई मीडियम सेट किया य पे अब
यहां पर फर्स्ट नेम में हमने क्या
डाला डि फोनिक्स सॉरी डि
फोनिक्स
स्पाइडी यह थोड़ा सा पेचीदा है
स्पाइडी गो प क्लिक किया
इट्स रिफ्लेक्टिंग चलिए बहुत बढ़िया हम h1
h1 दे देते हैं h1 स्पाइडी गो पर क्लिक कर
देते हैं यह जैसा का तैसा रिफ्लेक्ट हो
रहा है ठीक है बहुत बढ़िया कंट्रोल य करके
इसको देखते हैं स्पाइडी क्या हो रहा है
भाई यहां पे अभी देखिए यहां पे अगेन ये
सैनिटाइज हो रहा है यहां पे वैल्यू ठीक है
चलिए बहुत बढ़िया बात है सैनिटाइज होना
चाहिए तो इसका मतलब हम इनकोड करके देख
सकते हैं भैया तो हमारे पास इनकोडेड वाला
भी पड़ा हुआ है तो एक काम करते हैं ना
इनकोडेड वाला यूज कर लेते हैं दोनों में
एक बार गो पे क्लिक कर अब देखो इनकोडेड
वाला भी यूज किया यहां पर इनकोडेड जैसा का
तैसा प्रिंट हो गया भैया इट डन गेट
एग्जीक्यूटेड यानी कि यहां पे कुछ ज्यादा
ही हाई सिक्योरिटी लगी हुई है हाई वाले
लेवल पे मतलब यहां पे यह भी काम नहीं कर
रहा है हमारा तो अब क्या करें व्हाट वी
कैन डू नाउ तो एक काम करते हैं व्हाट वी
आर गोइंग टू डू हम हम एक डिफरेंट टैग को
यूज करके ट्राई करते हैं जस्ट ट्राइम
डिफरेंट टैग ठीक है तो हम ए का एचटीएमएल
का एच आरएफ यूज कर लेते एक बार एक बार ये
वाला ट्राई करते हैं यह रहा एच आरएफ इसको
कॉपी मार लेते हैं इसमें थोड़ा सा
मॉडिफिकेशन कर लेते हैं लेट्स मॉडिफाई अ
लिटिल बिट एंड मॉडिफाई क्या करते हैं
भाई यहां पे यह वेबसाइट चेंज कर देते हैं
एटीपीए एल क कर देते हैं एल क एंड यहां पर
कर देते हैं
हैक ठीक है तो तो ये हमने कर दिया ये हमने
यूआरएल एचआरएफ टैग क्रिएट कर दिया इसको हम
एक बार ट्राई मारते हैं लेट्स ट्राई
इट कॉपी किया यहां
पे
ओके यहां फर्स्ट नेम में डाल दिया हैक्ड
सेकंड नेम में भी हमने यहां पे ये वाली
चीज कर दी हैक्ड करके यहां पे कर देते हैं
डि
फ्रक्स यहां पे डि फ्रक्स डाल देते हैं बस
वो कीवर्ड डाल देते हैं ताकि हमें पता चल
जाए एंड यहां पे गो पे क्लिक कर देते हैं
अरे भाई ये क्या हो रहा है ये वैसे ऐसे
टाइप हो गया ये भी टाइप हो गया कंट्रोल य
करते हैं एंड यहां प देखते हैं हैक्ड क्या
हो रहा है भाई अगेन व्ट व्हाट इट इज व्हाट
इज हैपनिंग यहां हमने एच आरएफ किया इट गॉट
सैनिटाइज्ड अ यहां पे सैनिटाइज हो जा रहा
है आपका एक काम कर देते हैं वी आर गोइंग
टू डू वन थिंग हम इसको ना इसको इनकोड करते
हैं चलो चलो इसको भी इनकोड कर देते हैं सो
लेट्स गो टू द बॉब
शूट लेट्स टाइप इट य हैक्ड वाली चीज इसको
टाइप किया हमने यहां पे इसको यूआरएल इनकोड
करते हैं सो शुड वी डू यूआरएल इनकोड चलिए
यूआरएल इनकोड कर देते हैं एंड इसको हम
कॉपी कर लेते हैं लेट्स कॉपी
इट लेट्स कॉपी इट लेट्स डाउन यह वैसे
होमवर्क है आपका लेकिन ट्राई करते हैं एक
बार यहां पे हमने किया दोनों सेम ही करते
हैं भाई गो प क्लिक किया अगेन कुछ नहीं
हुआ यहां पे नथिंग हैपन एक्चुअली नथिंग
हैपन यहां पर क्या हो सकता है आप लोग कुछ
बताइए बेस 64 करें है ना चलो बेस 64 करें
तो भाई साहब बोल रहे हैं बेस 64 करने
को तो चलिए बेस 64 ट्राई आउट कर लेते हैं
लेट्स अ लेट्स ट्राई आउट बेस 64 तो हमने
यहां पे ये किया इनकोड एज बेस 64 ट्राई
आउट कर लेते हैं ठीक है एंड यहां पे हमने
इसको कॉपी किया लेट्स पुट इट डाउन हियर तो
हमने यहां पे इसको अ डाला यहां पे हमने
डाला एंड यहां पे गो पे क्लिक किया एंड
अगेन नथिंग इज हैपनिंग ठीक है यहां पे बेस
64 में भी हमारा कुछ नहीं हु अब हम एक काम
करते हैं
सॉरी लेट्स डू वन थिंग हमारा जो यह टैग है
एच आरफ वाला इसको कॉपी कर लेते हैं बॉब
शूट पर चलते
हैं ठीक है हम यहां पर इसको इनकोड एस
यूआरएल करते
हैं ठीक है एंड अगेन इसको इनकोड कर देते
हैं यूआरएल तो दो बार इनकोडिंग कर लेते
हैं ठीक
है ठीक है दो बार यहां पर इनकोडिंग किया ए
लेट्स गिव इट ई यहां पे दो बार डबल
इनकोडिंग डाला यहां पे गो पे क्लिक किया
अगेन इट्स स्टिल द सेम थिंग ठीक है अगेन
हमें क्या मिला
अ अगेन सेम चीजें मिली चलिए ठीक है कोई
बात नहीं अगेन हम क्या करते हैं आप लोग
बताइए मुझे आप लोग बताइए आपको अगर कुछ लग
रहा है तो बताइए मुझे बताने में क्या ही
दिक्कत है व्हाट वी आर गोइंग टू डू जो डबल
इनकोडेड है इसको इसको इनकोड कर देते हैं
बेस 64 में एंड देन लेट्स ट्राई इट
आउट सी कंट्रोल सी कर लेते हैं लेट्स
ट्राई इट आउट
यहां पर डालते फर्स्ट नेम में य डालते हैं
ए लेटस क्लिक न गो अगेन सेम
थिंग डबल कोड डबल कोड भी किया था हमने
नथिंग हैप राइट कुछ हुआ नहीं था ओके सो
लेट्स कॉपी
इट इंपैक्ट हो सकता है ना इसको चेंज करोगे
यू कैन चेंज इट टू द
एक्सस तो ज्यादा इंपैक्टफुल हो
जाएगा अब यहां पर हम क्या कर देते हैं
यूआरएल तो हमने इनकोड कर ही दिया था लेट्स
डू वन थिंग लेट्स डू
एचटीएमएल इनकोडिंग एक एचटीएल इनकोडिंग
करते हैं एंड कॉपी कर लेते हैं इसको लेटस
गिव इट ट्राई यहां पर ट्राई यहां पर ट्राई
गो प क्लिक करते हैं अगेन सेम थिंग हैपन
लेट्स डबल इनकोड इट एट एचटीएमएल तो
एटीएमएल का डबल इनकोडिंग करते हैं यहां पर
कंट्रोल सी लेटस सी एंड व एंड यहां पर गो
प क्लिक कर देते अगेन नहीं हो रहा ठीक है
समझ में आरहा
है यूज अनदर पेलो ठीक है अनदर पेलो भी यूज
कर लेंगे कोई दिक्कत नहीं है हम अनदर
पेलोड चलो आपके कहने प अनदर पेलोड आई
फ्रेम ही यूज कर लेते हैं र जस्ट यूजिंग
आई फ्रेम सो यहां पर हम क्या कर देते हैं
लेट्स गिव इट आई फ्रेम इनकोड एस य बाइनरी
प एक बार ट्राई कर लेते हैं ठीक है बाइनरी
प एक बार ट्राई कर लेते हैं लेटस सी ओके
नॉट
हैपनिंग ओके नथिंग ठीक है एक काम करते हैं
पेस्ट करते हैं इनकोड एस लेट्स गिव
इट नहीं यह तो खैर नहीं
होगा मैं इसको इनकोड कर देता हूं एक
[संगीत]
बार बेस
64 बेस 64 कर देते हैं हां देखते हैं
देखते हैं इसको वापस से ब 64 करते हैं डबल
डबल इनकोडिंग एंड यहां पर मैंने यहां पे
पेस्ट किया आई फ्रेम पेस्ट किया एंड यहां
पे गो पे क्लिक किया अगेन आईन थिंक की कुछ
हुआ है कुछ हुआ क्या कुछ नहीं हुआ नथिंग
हैपन राइट सो व्हाट वी आर गोइंग टू डू
जस्ट रिमूव
इट पेस्ट इट यर यूज एंड ऑ देन पास द
पेलो
ओके आस्की करते हैं आस्की ठीक है चलो
आस्की कर देते हैं सब यूज सब करवा लो भाई
सब करवा लो सही है
चलो आस्की यहां पर पेलोड यूज किया यहां पर
डाला य सेम होता है सेम हुआ इसको डबल
इनकोड कर देते हैं आसकी आसकी में क्या भाई
किसी का नहीं हुआ क्या बताओ कैसे होगा
यहां किया यहां किया आप ही लोग के जो कह
रहे हो वही कर रहा हूं मैं आस्की कर लिया
भाई एक् ठीक है थैंक यू ब्रदर लेट्स गो टू
द लेट्स गो डू वन
थिंग ये मैंने बोला ना ये
कॉम्प्लेक्शन में आपका ये काम हो जाएगा
ठीक
है देखो ये चलो अभी मैं नहीं बोलूंगा
लेकिन फिर भी स्टिल तुम जैसे जैसे बोल रहे
हो वैसे वैसे करते हैं एचआरएफ ही लेते हैं
फिर से अगेन डालते हैं यहां पे एंड दिस
टाइम व्हाट वी आर गोइंग टू डू इनकोड एज
एंड दिस टाइम वी आर गोइंग टू
डू हेक्स नहीं हेक्स में यार कुछ नहीं
होगा वैसे तो नथिंग विल हैपन सो इनकोड
करते हैं यहां पे हैश फॉर्मेट में एव में
तो नहीं करेंगे अ हैश में है यहां पे
एव ना ना ना ना ना
ना एक सिंपल सा यहां पे करते हैं इनकोड एज
एंड लेट्स गो इनकोड इट
[संगीत]
एट यूआरएल इसको इनकोड कर देते हैं
html4 में एंड नाउ लेट्स कॉपी इट एंड
लेट्स ट्राई इट आउट हियर लेट्स ट्राई इट
आउट हियर एंड गो अगेन सेम चीज सेम चीजें
ठीक है सेम चीज यहां पे आ रही
है लो सेट नहीं है भाई करंट लेवल हाई है
देखो ना यहां पे हाई है हाई है यहां
पे ठीक है यह हाई है अब देखो यहां पे यहां
पे कुछ भी नहीं हो रहा नथिंग इज हैपनिंग
राइट नाउ वी आर गोइंग टू डू वन थिंग क्या
हम करने वाले हैं चलिए नाउ वी आर गोइंग टू
यूज बब शूट यहां पे एंड बब शूट में कुछ
चीजें हम करने वाले हैं चलिए बॉब शूट में
आ गए हम यहां पे फिलहाल जस्ट रिमूव
इट टारगेट पे प्रॉक्सी प चलते यहां प
प्रॉक्सी प चलते हैं यहां पे एंड लेट्स
इनेबल द बप ठीक है भैया बप हमारे इनेबल हो
गए यहां पर सेम हम करते हैं पैरामीटर डाल
देते हैं डि फ्रक्स एंड यहां पर हमने डाल
दिया व्हाट वी आर गोइंग टू ऐड स्पाइडी ठीक
है यहां पर डाल दिया यहां पे बब शूट में
प्रॉक्सी को ऑन कर देते हैं एंड लेट्स
क्लिक ऑन गो जैसे ही गो पे क्लिक किया
यहां पे आ चुका है यहां पे इसको रिपीटर को
भेज देते हैं जस्ट सेंडिंग इट टू रिपीटर
इंटरसेप्ट ऑफ कर देते हैं रिपीटर पे चलते
हैं एंड
दैट्ची जें तो यहां डिफ्रॉक्ड स्पाइडी
सिंपली यहां पे रिफ्लेक्ट हो रही है बट अब
जो है हम यहां पे डेनिक्स के जगह पे जैसा
कि मैंने बोला अ वी वर ट्राइप लोड
एचटीएमएल पेलोड तो व्हाट वी आर गोइंग टू
डू वी आर गोइंग टू यूज
h1 डि फ्रॉक्स
डाला यहां पे h1 में यहां पे हमने डिफन
डाल दिया एंड यहां पे सेम चीजें हम यहां
स्पाइडी के लिए डाल देते हैं सेम चीजें वी
आर गोइंग टू ऐड एज
स्पाइडी स्पाइडी ठीक है यहां पे हमने गो
पे क्लिक किया अगेन डिफ्रॉक्ड हो रहा है
हमारा अगेन ये
ट्रंकेट्स
जें यहां पे एंड इट्स नॉट गेटिंग
रिफ्लेक्टेड जैसा कि हमें चाहिए था ठीक है
वी आर नॉट गेटिंग इट नाउ व्हाट वी आर
गोइंग टू डू हम एक चीज और कर सकते हैं
इसको हम चेंज एक बार रिक्वेस्ट मेथड चेंज
करके देखते हैं पोस्ट क्रिएट कर देते हैं
पोस्ट कर देते हैं एंड यहां पे फर्स्ट नेम
डिफ्रॉक जो है h1 h2 गो पे क्लिक कर देते
हैं लेट्स सी व्हाट इज हैपनिंग इफ वयी आर
गेटिंग डे फोनिक्स वीी आर नॉट गेटिंग
एनीथिंग कुछ भी हमें नहीं मिल रहा है यहां
पे सो वी आर गोइंग टू यूज द ट्रंक अ
इनकोडेड जो इनकोडिंग हमने की थी यहां से
उठा लेते हैं इनकोडिंग तो हमने यहां पे
इनकोडिंग ये वाली यूज की
थी चलिए यहां पर ब सिंपल सा एक बार फंडा
यहां पर सिंपल सा इसको इनकोड कर देते
हैं एव एक ही इंक्लूड एक ही करते इनकोड
मल्टीपल इनकोड नहीं करेंगे तो हम यहां प
डिकोडर प चलते हैं इनकोड कर देते हैं यहां
पे एंड इनकोड एस यूआरएल एंड ट्स इट हमने य
पर इनकोड
किया लेट्स पुट इट डाउन रिपीटर प चलते हैं
यहां पर यहां पर हमने सॉरी
सॉरी यहां हमने इसको पुट डाउन किया एंड
यहां पर हमने गो प क्लिक किया ठीक है नाउ
लेट्स सी इफ इट इज रिफ्लेक्टिंग ना इट इज
नॉट रिफ्लेक्टिंग ठीक है ये रिफ्लेक्ट
नहीं हो रहा तो बैक कर देते हैं हम यहां
पे अगेन हम अपने गेट वाले मेथड पर चले आते
हैं ठीक है यहां पर सिंपल सा चलाया अब
देखो यहां प यहां
पे क्या बोल रहे
हो सर दाढ़ी अच्छी लग अरे थैंक
यू क्या क्या
स्क्रिप्ट
स्क्रिप्ट टैग हां बिल्कुल यूज कर सकते हो
बिल्कुल यूज कर सकते हो स्क्रिप्ट टैग भी
यूज कर सकते हो देखो यहां पर तुम आराम से
स्क्रिप्ट टैग भी यूज कर सकते हो एचटीएमएल
के यहां पे जैसे हमने डाला स्क्रिप्ट ठीक
है
अलर्ट एंड यहां पे वन डाल देते हैं ठीक है
यहां पे
स्क्रिप्ट स्क्रिप्ट ये हमने डाल दिया ठीक
है तो हमने यहां पर भी डाला यहां प भी
डाला एंड यहां पे गो पे क्लिक कर देते हैं
एंड यू कैन यूज दिस कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं अब
यहां प कंट्रोल यू कर देते हैं यहां
कंट्रोल यू कर देते हैं कंट्रोल एफ कर
देते हैं स्क्रिप्ट देखते हैं यहां पे ये
देखो यहां पे कहां पे कहां पे ये निकला है
भाई कहां पे चला
है हां ये रहा ये
ट्रंकेट्स कॉपी इट लेट्स इनकोड इट ठीक है
डिकोड पे चलते हैं यहां पे स्क्रिप्ट टैग
डाला इनकोड एज
लेट्स ठीक है यूआरएल कोड एंड यूआरएल कोड
डबल इनकोडिंग कर दिया हमने एक में डाल के
देख लेते हैं यहां पे एक में डाला एक में
यहां पे डाला गो पे क्लिक किया अगेन सेम
चीज यहां पे हो रही है ठीक है कंट्रोल यू
करेंगे यहां पे कंट्रोल एफ करेंगे अलर्ट
करेंगे नथिंग वी आर गेटिंग क्योंकि वेलकम
के पास आएगा ये तो वेलकम यहां पे आया एंड
लेट्स नेट लेट्स चेक नेक्स्ट वेलकम ये
वाला कुछ इस तरीके से एज अ प्रिंट ये चीज
हो जा रही है डायरेक्टली ये ऐ सब प्रिंट
हो रही है एंड इसको हम क्या कर देते हैं
वी आर गोइंग टू डू वन थिंग वी आर गोइंग टू
डू यहां पर डबल कोट क्लोजिंग डबल कोट
क्लोजिंग दे देते हैं एंड यहां पे अब इसको
इनकोड कर देते हैं एज अ यूआरएल लेट्स
चेक यहां प हमने किया यहां प हमने किया गो
पे क्लिक किया अगेन नथिंग इज हैपनिंग अब
इसको हम क्या कर लेते हैं डबल
कोट ये डबल कोट स्लश क्लोजिंग इनकोड एज
यूआरएल एंड इनकोड एज डबल यूआरएल एंड लेट्स
ट्राई इट आउट ये कैसे भी नहीं होगा मैं
आपको बस दिखा रहा हूं बट ये होगा नहीं इस
बात की फुल गारंटी है यहां पे मैंने डाला
नथिंग जज हैपन ठीक है अब देखो यहां पे
नहीं नहीं नहीं नहीं अच्छा मुझे आप लोग
मुझे बता रहे हो कि यह करो सर वो करो सर
सच बताओ मुझे आप में से किसी का हुआ किसी
का यह चीज यह चीज किसी का हुआ यह बताइए
मुझे बताइए
ना आप में से किसी का हुआ पहले यह बताइए
तब मैं आपको बताऊंगा तब मैं आपसे बात
करूंगा मुझे पता है किसी का नहीं हुआ
होगा
जल्दी कोई अगर कर रहा है
तो कमेंट करके देख लीजिए नहीं होगा यार
नहीं होगा नहीं होगा कमेंट करके भी नहीं
होगा
बताइए नहीं
होगा हां अगर ट्राई कोई कर रहा है तो भी
नहीं
होगा ठीक है
देखो देखो देखो देखो यहां
पे हां मैं य पर सिंपल सा
एक एक वो डालता हूं एच आरएफ यह वाली डाल
दी हमने ठीक है ना यह वाली हमने डाल दी एच
आरफ वाली ओके यहां पर मैं स्पाइडी ही डाल
देता हूं सिंपल सा मैं यहां पे गो प क्लिक
करता हूं गो प यहां पर हमें एच आरफ आ अभी
हम एक लाइव वेबसाइट प भी जाएंगे उस भी
करेंगे देखते रहिएगा लाइव वाली और मजेदार
होगी आपके लिए
ठीक है अब हमें यहां पर सेम जैसा के तैसा
मिल रहा है ठीक है अब हम यहां पर क्या
करते हैं ना यहां पर यूआरएल इनकोड डिकोड
करते हैं य ठीक है यूआरएल इनकोडिंग इनकोड
इनकोडर यहां पर सर्च करते हैं चलते य पे
यह रहा यूआरएल इनकोड यहां यह
रहा यह रहा बहुत सारे आ
गए ये सिंपल वाला है इसको हटा दो दिस वन इ
ल्स सिंपल इसको हटा दो ये वाला है हमारा
तो इनकोड वाले पे आ गए हमने यहां पे ल डाल
दिया evil.com हैक करके यहां पे डाल दिया
अब इसको ना हम कुछ अलग-अलग तरीकों से
इनकोड करने की कोशिश करेंगे ठीक
है अ बिल्कुल बिल्कुल बिलकुल अ एज आई अ रि
जॉइड अ आई सी यह स्पेशल कैरेक्टर को
एचटीएमएस में कन्वर्ट कर दे रहा है आई
बायपास इन ड तो उसमें तो सोर्स कोड था
अवेलेबल हां इसमें थोड़ा सा डिफरेंट है
मैं आपको बता रहा हूं
यहां पर थोड़ा सा ट्रिकी पार्ट है थोड़ा
सा समझिए अगर मैंने इसलिए बोला था कि आप
लोग ट्राई कीजिएगा एज अ होमवर्क शायद आपका
दिमाग काम कर जाए वहां पे अब मैं एक सिंपल
सा फंड कर रहा हूं यहां पे नॉर्मल सा
एचआरएफ यूज कर रहा हूं मैं ठीक है यहां पे
नॉर्मल सा एचआरएफ यूज करके एंड वी आर
गोइंग टू डेस्टिनेशन कैरेक्टर सेट जो है
ना हम यूटीएफ 8 पे पॉपुलर पे अभी है एंड
एक ऐसा ब्राउजर हमें चाहिए इसके लिए ना जो
यूटीएफ 7 सपोर्ट करता है बट ठीक है चलो एक
बार ट्राई आउट करते हैं अदर यहां पे एंड
एंड एंड यूटीएफ से प आ जाते एक बार
इनकोडिंग के लिए एंड यहां पे इनकोड करके
देखते हैं ठीक है सो लेट्स ट्राई इट आउट
हियर मैंने कॉपी किया यहां पे एंड यहां पे
मैंने इसको पेस्ट किया यहां हमने स्पाइडी
ही डाला एंड यहां प गो प क्लिक किया अगेन
सेम दिस इज नॉट हैपनिंग राइट सो दिस इज
नॉट हैपनिंग एट ऑल तो यहां पर एक काम कर
देते हैं कंट्रोल सी किया इसको यहां डाला
इनकोड किया ठीक है अगेन वी गट हियर यहां
इनकोडेड यहां लाते हैं इसमें स्पाइडी ही
डाल देते हैं सॉरी स्पाइडी डाल देते हैं
एंड यहां पे गो पे क्लिक कर देते हैं अगेन
सेम चीजें हुई यहां पे नथिंग इज हैपनिंग
वी आर नॉट गेटिंग द लिंक्स एंड ऑल कुछ
हमें लिंक वगैरह कुछ नहीं मिल रहा ए सिंपल
एज दैट तो यहां पे अब हम क्या कर देते हैं
वी आर गोइंग टू टेक
द
एचआरएफ यहां
पे यहां पे जा रहे हैं
किसी
यस यू कैन चेंज
एचटीएमएल एचटीएमएल टू एक्सेसेस क्रॉस साइट
स्क्रिप्टिंग नहीं जा भाई नहीं होगा नहीं
होगा तुम कुछ भी कर लो ठीक है सच बता रहा
हूं मैं अब देखो यहां पे यहां पे इनकोड ईच
लाइन सेपरेटली एक बार ट्राई करते हैं
यूटीएफ से में इनकोड ईच लाइन सेपरेटली यह
ट्राई करते हैं यह वाला मोड स्टार्ट करते
हैं एंड यहां पे इनकोड करते हैं एंड नाउ
वी आर गोइंग टू टेक इट लेट्स ट्राई इट आउट
यहां पर स्पाइडी स्पाइडी ही रखते हैं जो
भी रखना है रख दो यार यहां पर गो प क्लिक
कर देते हैं एंड वी गट हियर नथिंग कुछ भी
हमें नहीं मिला नाउ हम क्या करते हैं एक
लाइन यहां कर देते हैं यहां पे नीचे जाते
हैं नीचे जाते हैं एंड हियर
यूटीएफ 16 वी आर गोइंग टू ट्राई यर लेट्स
इनकोड इट एंड वी गट द इनकोडिंग हियर लेट्स
ट्राई इट आउट यर यहां डालते हैं स्पाइडी
में डालते हैं एंड प क्लिक कर देते हैं
एंड अगेन हमें कुछ भी एटली कुछ भी नहीं
मिला है यहां पे ठीक है यडी 16 भी हमने
ट्राई कर लिया ये कैरेक्टर सेट है जो आप
यूज कर सकते हैं अलग-अलग कक्टर सेट्स
बायपास करने के लिए ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं
कई बार लेकिन वो ब्राउजर उस तरीके का
सपोर्टेबल भी होना चाहिए यहां पे याद
रखिएगा तो वी आर गोइंग टू ट्राई आउट आस्की
हमने ऑलरेडी शायद कर लिया था लेट्स ट्राई
आसो एंड लेट्स इनकोड
इट नो
नोन चलो एक काम करते हैं यूडीएफ
करके एक बार देख लेते लेटस ट
आउट ओके वी गट इट यर लेटस ट आउट र यहां पर
डाला एंड यहां पर हमने कुछ भी डाल दिया य
पर हमने गो प क्लिक किया ए नथिंग हैपन ठीक
है सर यह
[संगीत]
होगा बिल्कुल बिल्कुल देखो मैं एक चीज
बताता हूं बवप का य इजेक्शन का वाला है ना
करंट हाई वाला मैं आपको एक चीज दिखाता हूं
देखि य पर ज बी वप एचटीएमएल
इंजेक्शन हाई ठीक है रिफ्लेक्टर गेट हाई
ठीक है अब मैं आपको एक चीज दिखाता य पर
यहां पर चलते हैं
एक एक राइट अप है य ठीक है नीचे आते हैं
राइट अप किसी ने लिखा है नीचे आते हैं
पहले इसने क्या किया लो वाली सॉल्व की
बहुत अच्छी बात है सिंपल सा है मीडियम
वाला सॉल्व किया सिंपल सा है उसके बाद पे
हाई वाला सॉल्व किया एंड यहां पे आ रहा है
हियर द इनपुट इज सैनिटाइज यूजिंग द
एचटीएमएल स्पेशल कैरेक्टर्स सो वी नीड टू
यूज डिफरेंट टाइप ऑफ इनकोडिंग वी नीड
ब्राउजर दैट सपोर्ट्स यूटीएफ 7 एंड द
पेलोड स्क्रिप्ट अलट लुक लाइक दिस दिस दिस
व्हेन इनकोडेड इन यूटीएफ 7 समझ में आ रहा
है मतलब इस तरह का कुछ पेलोड आपको देखने
को मिलेगा इस तरीके का ठीक है अब ये पेलोड
जो है इस तरीके का पेलोड होगा और अगर
ब्राउजर सपोर्टेड होगा टीए 7 के लिए देन
आप इसको सॉल्व कर सकते हैं कहने का मतलब
यह है मतलब कि अगर यह ब्रा ब्राउजर
सपोर्टेड है यूटीएफ से ने हमने यह किया और
हमने गो पे क्लिक किया तो हमें यहां पे
रिजल्ट्स जो है वो देखने को मिल सकते हैं
बट उसके लिए वो सपोर्टेड होना चाहिए ठीक
है गॉट
इट हां भा हां चलेगा सर एटीएल इंजेक्शन
एंड एक्सएसएस में फर्क है क्या माइनर फर्क
है माइनर फर्क तो है ही एट एग्जैक्ट सेम
नहीं है एटी इंजेक्शन इज इंजेक्टिंग
एचटीएमएल टैक्स कोड्स इनसाइड द क्लाइंट
इनसाइड द ब्राउजर एंड वो आपका वहां पे
रिफ्लेक्ट हो रहा है बेसिकली एंड सो एंड
जब आप एक्सेसेस की बात करते हैं तो वहां
पे आप बेसिकली जावास्क्रिप्ट को इंजेक्ट
कर रहे होते हो ठीक है ओके अब देखो ये तो
आपको समझ में आ गया अब देखो यहां
पे 2019 का ये नहीं ठीक है सॉल्यूशन ऑफ
बवप यहां पे चलते हैं यहां नीचे आते हैं
ये देखिए यहां पे नीचे आते हैं मीडियम
वाले है
ये हार्ड वाले अब देखो दिस इज यूजिंग द
एटीए स्पेशल कैरेक्टर फंक्शन व्हिच
रिस्ट्रिक्ट्स द यूज ऑफ़
html4 एज इन यूटीएफ से हैव डिफरेंट कोड
पॉइंट्स देन यूटीएफ ए सो दैट दे आर नॉट
स्केप अनलेस कन्वर्ट द आउटपुट इन टीएफ ए
फॉर मोर डिटेल्स विजिट हियर मतलब कि यहां
पे एक ब्राउजर जो यूटीएफ 8 में बाय
डिफॉल्ट आपके जो है ना वो अ ऑलरेडी पास
करती है उसको हम कैसे भी यूटीएफ से में
अगर कर दें प्रीवियस जो आपका अ यूटीएफ से
है इन कैरेक्टर सेट है तब जाके ये चीज
यहां पे काम करेगी अदर वाइज काम नहीं
करेगी सिंपल सा फंडा यानी कि दिस इज अ नॉट
पॉसिबल दिस इज नॉट पॉसिबल सिंपल सा फंडा
यही है समझ में आ रहा है इतना इतना ची यह
कहीं पर भी आपको कहीं कुछ इसका मिलने वाला
नहीं है तो यह तो मैंने सोचा आप में से
कोई दिमाग लगाएगा कुछ लाइक थोड़ा वो करेगा
दिमाग का दही करेगा लेकिन ठीक है तो अब इस
पर आप लोग ज्यादा दिमाग ना लगाए तो ज्यादा
बेटर है मेरे ख्याल से ठीक है गट इट बट
इतना समझ में आ गया एटी इंजेक्शन क्या हो
रहा है किस तरीके से चीज हो रही है एंड
किस तरीके से रिफ्लेक्शन हो रही है चलिए
अब हम क्या कर देते हैं एक प्रोग्राम ले
लेते हैं वी आर गोइंग टू टेक अ प्रोग्राम
चलिए सो लेट्स हैव
इट
चलिए यहां पर हम चलते हैं ओपन बग बाउंट पर
ओपन बग बाउंट
पे मैं आपको दिखाता हूं किस तरीके से आप
हंट कर सकते हैं किस किस किस तरीके से आप
पहुंच सकते हैं एटी इंजेक्शन के लिए ट्राई
आउट मार सकते हैं वो मैं आपको सब दिखाऊंगा
तो लेट्स ओपन ठीक
है सर आपने हमारी बात का रिप्लाई नहीं
दिया क्या बात थी भाई देखा नहीं ना यार
मैं मैसेज थोड़ी ना देखता हूं मैसेज नहीं
देखता यार कभी-कभी देख लेता हूं
मैं सर मैंने आपके वीडियोस की सीरीज
स्टार्ट की है मैंने दो क्लास ले ली है जो
आपने पका बताया था उसमें मैंने ₹ का
पेमेंट नहीं हो पा रहा है उसमें पे कैसे
करू पाकिस्तान से अगर हो या आउट ऑफ इंडिया
से तो थोड़ा मुश्किल है भाई ठीक है वोह
पेमेंट
में हो जाएगी
भाई थैंक यू आरसी टेक दिव्यांश भाई थैंक
यू
ठीक है चलिए ओपन बक बाउंडी पर चलते हैं
लाइव टारगेट वी आर गोइंग टू चूज वी आर
गोइंग टू चूज अ लाइव टारगेट लेट इट ओपन
मजा
आएगा मजा आएगा भाई अभी
तो
चलिए ठीक है अरे भाई ओपन हो जा यार क्या
दिक्कत आ रही
है क्या बात है थैंक यू रितिक रितिक
जी अरे ओपन हो जा यार ऐसे क्या जल् लेट कर
रहा
है ओपन कर लिया हमने
अब देखिए ए इंजेक्शन किन तरीको से आप
ट्राई आउट कर सकते हैं क्याक तरीके हो
सकते हैं चलिए हम नीचे आते हैं यहां पर
कोई रिसेंट प्रोग्राम से प्रोग्राम ले
लेते हैं न
रैली
एल्ट सिलिया कंटेंट एआई ठीक है न करते हैं
इसमें क्या है इनका लीज ड इफ इसको ओपन कर
लेते हैं लीड इफ को क्या है भाई
लेट लेट्स सी गाइस व्ट इ दे
बग रिपोर्टिंग भी करवाऊंगी टेंशन मत लो बग
रिपोर्टिंग भी करंगा बिल्कुल
अरे डाउन नहीं चल रहा है रली डट इनो यहां
तो ऐसा कोई टम यह चीज नहीं हटाओ
इसको फलम फ्रांस की कौन सी वेबसाइट है
फ्रांस ह हटाओ य कौन सी है बट
स्लैप चलो इसको ओपन करके
देखो लेट्स ओपन इट बड बड क्लैप बड स्लैप
पता नहीं क्या है जो भी है तो यहां पे
हमने ओपन किया इसको मैं ट्रांसलेट कर देता
हूं क्यों ये समझ नहीं आएगा ट्रांसलेट
नहीं है क्या
यार ओ भाई इसमें ट्रांसलेट का ऑप्शन तो
होता है ना शायद होता है ना ट्रांसलेट यार
ट्रांसलेट पेज
अ ओके सपोर्ट नहीं करता तो हम इसको क्या
करते हैं ना यार कम में ओपन कर लेते हैं
ट्रांसलेट तुम यहां नहीं करोगे मैं कम में
ओपन करता कम भाई अपना सब ट्रांसलेट करता
है अपना क्रम भाई जिंदाबाद सब ट्रांसलेट
करता है इंग्लिश ट्रांसलेट हो गया ये चलिए
अ इसमें ऑटोमेटिक ऑटोमेटिक है यहां पे ठीक
है तो हमने यहां पे ये हमारा टारगेट है
बिग फैन सर अरे थैंक यू अभिलाष
जी अभिलाष सर धन्यवाद तो
चलिए तो यहां पे आ गए हैं ये हमारा टारगेट
है बड स्प ड सीज करके एंड व्हाट वी आर
गोइंग टू डू वी आर गोइंग टू फाइंड सम एटील
इंजेक्शन तो हम क्या करेंगे सबसे पहला
हमारा क्या मोटो क्या र है देख मोटो क्या
रहेगा तो य पर पहले एव डालते हैं भाई सबसे
पहला सिंपल सा फंडा h1
डिक्स प तो रिफ्लेक्ट करा लेते फोनिक्स
लिख के एटर मारते देखते ट
ंग रिफ्लेक्ट हो रहा है कि नहीं तो यहां
कहीं पे रिफ्लेक्ट नहीं रिफ्लेक्ट हो रहा
है य प यह रहा डिक्स आ रहा है सॉरी वीड
नॉट फाइंड सर्च टम डिक्स तो इट इ
रिफ्लेक्टिंग र य अच्छी बात है अब हम य पर
एव डालते हैं एंड लेट्स एंटर एंटर किया
एंटर करने पे यह h1 का h1 जैसा का तैसा
रिफ्लेक्ट कर दे रहा है भाई यह यह तो
गड़बड़ चीज है h1 जैसा का तैसा रिफ्लेक्ट
हो रहा है दिस इज बैड थिंग लेट्स सी व्हाट
इज हैपनिंग इन सोर्स पेज कंट्रोल य किया
कंट्रोल एफ किया डि फनिक सर्च किया एंड
यहां पे दिक्कत दे रही है भैया दिक्कत
क्या है यह सैनिटाइज हो रहा है डे फोनिक्स
इज सैनिटाइजिंग तो यूआरएल इनकोड कर ले
क्या भाई चलो इनकोड ही कर लेते हैं क्या
ही कर सकते हैं दूसरा हमारे पास कोई काम
तो है नहीं इनकोड कर देते हैं h1 इनकोड कर
देते हैं यूआरएल पे यूआरएल इनकोड कर देते
हैं एंड कॉपी मार देते
हैं तो यहां इनकोड डालते हैं एंटर करते
हैं लेट्स सी ओ भाई इसने फिर से सेम वही
प्रिंट कर दिया सेम चीज कंट्रोल यू कर
देते हैं एंड यहां पे कहां पे आ रहा था
भाई
ये किसके बाद आ रहा था ये बड चप अच्छा ऊपर
में आ रहा है क्या ये नहीं नहीं ऊपर में
हां हां ये तो ऊपर में ही आ रहा है भाई तो
ऊपर में देख रहा है यहां पे ये रही टाइटल
पूरी की पूरी इनकोडिंग ओ शिट मैन यहां पे
भी ये सैनिटाइज हो रहा है डबल इनकोड करके
देखिएगा डबल इनकोड एस
यूआरएल डबल इनकोडिंग करते चलो डबल
इनकोडिंग किया हमने पेस्ट किया एंटर
किया बाप रे गजब भाई इतना शानदार वो कर
रहे हो तुम बचा रहे हो तुम इसको बचा लिया
इसने कोई बात
नहीं नाउ नेक्स्ट नेक्स्ट
ट्राई कूलर है थैंक यू सोर क थैंक यू
वेलकम ब्रदर
वेलकम अरे वेलकम भाई इनकोड कर देते हैं अब
एचटीएमएल एचटीएम इनकोड करे क्या एटील को
इंक्लूड किया जाए क्या चलो एटीएम इंक्लूड
करते हैं कॉपी मारते हैं हमारा काम क्या
है इनकोड डिकोड इनकोड डिकोड इसको एचटीएल
इनकोडिंग ट्राई आउट मार लेते हैं हट ये
जैसा ओए क्या हुआ ये नहीं हो रहा वो वही
चीज है वही रिफ्लेक्शन है सेम क्योंकि
एटीएमएल किया है डबल इनकोड करने से भी कोई
फायदा नहीं होगा बट स्टिल गिव इट अ ट्राई
ठीक है गिव इट ट्राई
सेम चीज वही आ जाएगी बनके आजा भाई आजा
अच्छा कुछ नहीं हुआ तो एक काम करते हैं
इसको य डालते हैं इनकोड एस नाउ बेस 64 बेस
64 में इनकोड करके मैं यहां पर इसको डाल
देता हूं देखते भाई कितनी तरह की लगा रखी
है सुरक्षा तो यहां पर हमने बेस 64 इनकोड
किया नीचे आते हैं
रे यार मुझे लगा कि हो जाएगा रिफ्लेक्ट
नहीं हुआ बेस 64 को डबल करते
हैं कंट्रोल
सी टी एंटर लेट सी कुछ हुआ क्या ओ हो नहीं
कुछ भी नहीं हुआ मुझे लगा रिफ्लेक्ट वो हो
जाएगा बट कुछ हुआ नहीं कोई भी टेंशन नहीं
है चेंज करते पेलोड को पेलोड इज दिस नाउ
एच आरफ भैया एच आरफ को लाते हैं एच आरफ को
यहां डालते हैं इनकोड एज बेस 64 करते हैं
इसको कॉपी मारते हैं इसको डालते हैं यहां
पे एंड देखते
हैं
टाटाटा कुछ भी नहीं आया अरे भाई कुछ नहीं
आया बड़ा दुख होता है यहां डाला इनकोड एस
किया बेस 64 किया एंड इनकोड एस बेस 64
दोबारा किया कॉपी मारा यहां आए यहां गए
यहां गए और यहां पे पेस्ट मार दिया एंटर
कर दिया
नहीं कुछ हुआ कुछ नहीं हो रहा भाई कोई बात
नहीं ना हम कुछ हम थोड़ी ना कुछ कह रहे
हैं भाई मत हो जाओ अब यहां पर फिर से हम
ट्राई मारेंगे हमारा काम है ट्राई ट्राई
ट्राई भाई बस ट्राई एंड ट्राई देखते जाइए
इनकोड
कीजिए
सॉरी आस्की आस्की आस्की पास्की यहां पर
करते हैं एक बार आस्की पास्की को लाते हैं
यहां पर एंड एंटर कर देते हैं आकी पास की
कुछ नहीं हुआ हमारा डबल इनकोड आसकी पास की
अगेन डबल इनकोडेड को कॉपी किया आसकी पास
की को यहां डाल देते हैं ए यहां पर गए हो
सकता है ये फीड वल्नरेबल ना हो भाई ऐसा भी
हो सकता है ये मत सोचना कि वल्नरेबल होगा
ही नहीं हुआ वल्नरेबल नहीं है ये मोस्टली
ऑलमोस्ट मेरे ख्याल से दिस इ नॉट गेटिंग
वल्नरेबल बहुत अच्छी बात है अब ये सेम चीज
आप चैट बॉक्स में डाल लो भाई अरे ये क्या
है लाइव चैट है क्या ट्रांसलेट इनटू
इंग्लिश करो भाई इसको क्या लिखा है ये चल
इंग्लिश में हो जा भाई अरे तुम इंग्लिश
नहीं होगे क्या ये नहीं होगा इंग्लिश में
तो मैं हेलो डालता हूं हू ईमेल में हेलो @
हेलो डालता हूं और यहां पर मैं यहां पर
पेलो डाल देता हूं कौन सा ए1 वाला इसके
चैट में भी अरे ये क्या हुआ है ये हुआ
क्या
ये यह पता नहीं ये राइट में कैसे शिफ्ट हो
गया कुछ चेंज हुआ है लेआउट शायद ओके रहने
देते हैं कोई बात नहीं अब यहां पे हमने ये
डाला h1 नाउ
लेट्स क्या डाउनलोड है यार डाउनलोड क्या
है समझा नहीं मैं हट यार चैट करो
भाई पता नहीं क्या हुआ वो कुछ मेल ल गई
है अय लाइव चैट यहां पर नहीं है तो चलो
कोई बात नहीं य आप लोग वो कर रहे हैं नीचे
आते य
प सॉरी जितने पैरामीटर्स है सबको
एक्सप्लोर करने का है तो वही सिंपल सा
फंडा है भैया पैरामीटर को एक्सप्लोर करने
का है तो कंट्रोल ए कंट्रोल
सी यहां पर
ओपन कर देते हैं ब सूट पर चल देते हैं बट
स्लाप बट स्लाप टारगेट पर चल देते हैं
एसटीटीपी प्रॉक्सी प चल देते एसटीटीपी
हिस्ट्री पर चल देते हैं कहां गया हमारा
बड बड बड
बड कहां है हमारे बला बचा बचा बप ऊपर ही
आएगा ना यार ये
तो यह रहा बचा आप यह रहा 301 क्यों आ रहा
है भाई इसमें
टारगेट प चलते हैं यहां
पे प्रॉक्सी प चलो इसको इसको रोक लेते
हैं इसको यहां से रोक ही लेते हैं भाई अरे
हट जाओ
यार लेट्स स्टॉप इट हियर चलो भाई अब तो आ
जाओगे यहां पे आ ग ठीक है राइट क्लिक किया
सेंड टू कहां सेंड टू स्पाइडर स्पाइडर में
ऐड कर दो यस कर दो एंड इंटरसेप्ट भगा दो
टारगेट में फिल्टर लगा दो सोली इन स्कोप
आइटम्स और बाकी सबको भगाओ और इसको लाओ बचा
आप आ गई भाई स्पाइडरिंग हो रही है
नाहा स्पाइडरिंग हो रही है बहुत सारी
स्पाइडरिंग हो रही
है न न ये देखिए पैरामीटर फाइंड करने में
लेट्स गिव इट पैरामीटर पैरामीटर बहुत
पैरामीटर है भाई सबमिट करो भाई सबमिट
पैरामीटर बहुत सारे पैरामीटर्स है कोई
पैरामीटर उठा लो 302 200 200 200 200 200
वाला कौन है कौन सा पैरामीटर है यह
पैरामीटर आ
गया य क्या पैरामीटर्स है है चलो जो भी
पैरामीटर है उससे क्या हमें क्या है हमें
पैरामीटर से मतलब होना चाहिए कोई सा भी
पैरामीटर आ जाए कोई फर्क नहीं पड़ता है
लेट्स सी दिस पैरामीटर ओके ओके
ओके दिस पैरामीटर
ओके चलने देते है इसको कोई दिक्कत नहीं है
चले ये स्पाइडर कर रहा है तब तक इसका
दूसरा स्पेक्ट देख लेते हैं अब आप दूसरा
एक तरीका क्या यूज कर सकते हैं ये देखिए
दूसरा तरीका क्या यूज कर सकते हैं चलिए
काम करते हैं हम चलते हैं एक अकाउंट
क्रिएट करते हैं इस कस्टमर जोन में चलते
देखते इसके सर्विसेस को एक्सप्लोर करते
हैं यहां पे मैं लॉग आउट कर देता हूं यहां
पे ठीक है कस्टमर जोन में चलते हैं यहां
पे मैं आई वांट टू रजिस्टर करते हैं टेंप
मेल ओपन कर लेते हैं टेंप
मेल
ठीक है टे मेल कर दिया चलिए बढ़िया है
यहां पर यहां जीमल में ओपन कर लेता हूं
कौन सा जीमल ओपन है भाई देख लेते
हैं चलिए यह वाली जीमेल है य प बापरे
कितने मेलस क्या क्या मेल आए हुए भाई बहुत
सारी मेल है यहां प मेल को मत देखना
तुम ओके सो व आर गोइंग टू डू वन थिंग यहां
पर हम रजिस्टर क्रिएट अकाउंट कर देते हैं
चलिए ठीक है तो ईमेल आईडी डाल देते हैं
टेप मेल से उठा के ठीक है ओके नहीं टे मेल
से नहीं रियल ईमेल डालते ईमेल तो रियल में
डालता हूं नितेश ताकि मेल आएगी तो पता
चलेगा पासवर्ड डाल देते
हैं ठीक है ड्रेसिंग मैन एंटर योर नेम तो
नेम में डाल देते हैं
राहुल
सिंह स्ट्रीट एड्रेस
में डाल देते हैं एक वहां
का जहां का ये
है
सॉरी अ आई वांट टू एंटर अदर बिलिंग इ फॉस
ठीक है ये इतना रहने देते हैं एंड सेव पे
क्लिक कर देते हैं आई होप कि रजिस्ट्रेशन
सक्सेसफुल हो जाए सक्सेसफुल हो चुकी है
बहुत बढ़िया यहां पे चलते हैं लॉग इन कर
लेते हैं लेट्स अ अच्छा ये लॉगइन हो चुके
है एक्सेस टू कस्टमर जोन चलिए तो हम लॉगइन
हो चुके हैं वेबसाइट पे चलते हैं नाउ वी
आर गोइंग टू अ ट्राई एनी प्रोडक्ट कोई सा
भी प्रोडक्ट लेते हैं ये वाला प्रोडक्ट है
इसको ले लेते हैं एंड इसको ड टू कार्ट कर
लेते हैं ऐड टू बास्केट लार्ज साइज में ड
टू बास्केट किया व्यू काट पे चलते
हैं वी आर ऑन द व्यू काट व्यू कार्ट यहां
पे कुछ भी हमें ऐसा एटीएल इंजेक्शन फाइंड
करने टाइप यहां कुछ हमें दिख नहीं रहा है
गोन पे क्लिक करते
हैं ओके नथिंग वी आर फाइंडिंग हियर यहां
सेलेक्ट करते हैं डिलीवरी
मेथड ऑनलाइन कार्ड ट्रांसफर ठीक है कैश ऑन
ली ऑनलाइन ही रहने देते हैं गो ऑन प क्लिक
करते
हैं गोन प क्लिक किया यहां पर एक चीज हमें
आई है इनपुट फील्ड ठीक है यहां पर इनपुट
फीड आई है अब इनपुट फील्ड में हम छेर छर
तो कर सकते हैं भाई इनपुट फील्ड में हम
नेम के जगह पर अपना अपना क्या डालेंगे
अपना पेलो डालते हैं ठीक है भैया तो नेम
के जगह पर हम यहां प पेलो डाल देते
हैं डि फोनिक्स वाली पेलो डाल देते हैं
चलिए य डि फोनिक्स पेलो उठाया नेम के जगह
पर हम य पेलो डाल देते
हैं ठीक है भैया य डाल दिया हमने बाकी तो
कुछ नहीं है नोट है नोट में भी हमने डि
फोनिक्स पेलो डाल दिया नोट वाला भी डाल
देते डिफ पेलोड ठीक है अब यहां पर जब हमने
पेलो डाल दिया तो हम इसको क्या करेंगे
फिनिश ऑर्डर करेंगे फिनिश ऑर्डर यहां पर
करते हैं ठीक है वी आर गोइंग टू डू फिनिश
ऑर्डर तो लेट्स क्लिक ऑन द फिनिश ऑर्डर
लेटस सी ट
ंग
नाउ यहां आ रहा है गो पे गेटवे गोप गेटवे
आ रहा है यहां पे दिस इज गोप गेटवे चलो
ठीक है अब यहां पर हम मेल चेक करते हैं
कोई मेल आई हैन के तरफ से यहां प्रमोशन
में एक मेल आई है ये देखिए यह प्रमोशन में
एक तो रजिस्ट्रेशन की मेल आई है एक दूसरी
मेल आई है अब देखो यह जो मेल आई है ना यह
मेल हमने ओपन किया यहां पे और यहां पे
हमें ट्रांसलेट टू इंग्लिश कर देते हैं
इसको हो रहा है क्या इंग्लिश
में हां द राइट गाय मेक्स द राइट डिसीजन
दिस वाज वन ऑफ देम दिस वाज न ठीक है थैंक
यू फॉर ऑर्डरिंग इन ऑनलाइन स्टोर जो भी है
हां यहां पे हमने यह देखो हमने यहां पे जो
पेलो डाला था अ एचआरएफ ये एचआरएफ यहां पे
विजिट डि फ्रॉक्स करके रिफ्लेक्ट हो रहा
है यहां पे रिफ्लेक्ट हो रहा है बट यहां
नीचे में रिफ्लेक्ट नहीं हो रहा है ये नोट
में जो हमने डाला था दिस इज नॉट गेटिंग
एग्जीक्यूटेड ये एज अ स्ट्रिंग नॉर्मल
एग्जीक्यूट हुई है बट यहां पे एज अ बटन एज
अ
क्लिकब्रिक्स
चलो अब यहां विजिट डेनिक्स पे मैं क्लिक
करूंगा इट शुड बी ओपनिंग de.com
इट इट इज ओपनिंग de.com एंड यहां पे ये
मेल जब आया तो वी गॉट द
फाइंड किया एक्चुअली फाइंड किया यू फाउंड
लाइव एटीएमएल इंजेक्शन इन दिस टारगेट ऑन
ओपन बग बाउंट जिसका टारगेट का नाम है अ
क्या है यार टारगेट का नाम क्या था अ
सिंपलिंक ये वेबसाइट है सिंप की ये
वेबसाइट है एंड ये एक्चुअल आपका एचटीएमएल
इंजेक्शन है इन द मेल जब हमें रिजल्ट मिला
सो वी फाउंड हियर कि हमें एक यहां विज डे
फोनिक्स करके आ चुका एंड इसका यूज आप
फिशिंग के लिए की जा सकती है
लाइक अपने आप को प्रिटेंड करने के लिए कि
हम इस सेम ऑथेंटिक कंपनी से ऑथेंटिकेशन के
लिए की जा सकती है यह चीज कर सकती है ठीक
है अब यहां पर अब देखो यहां पर देखो य पर
एक चीज दिखाता हूं तो मैं रिपोर्ट दिखाता
हूं य प एक चीज का देखो य एचटी एमएल
इंजेक्शन हैकर
वन ओपन करता हूं यहां पर कोई सा भी कुछ
मिला हमें कुछ है क्या एटीएल
इंजेक्शन बाउंट किसी को बाउंट का देख लेते
हैं यहां पे मिला एक फर्स्ट 50 बढ़िया है
यार देखो भाई एचटीएमएल इंजेक्शन सर्च करने
प हमारी वीडियो आ रही है टॉप पे डेनिक्स
अकेडमी देखा यह टॉप पे आ रही है यहां एक
राइट अप है यह क्या है माय फर्स्ट 250
एटीएमएल इंजेक्शन ठीक है लेट्स डू वन थिंग
क्या किया इन्होंने
[संगीत]
अ चाट सेशन इंजेक्ट एचटीएमएल अ एंड एंडेड
चार्ट सेशन आई रिक्वेस्टेड फ द फॉर द कन्फ
टू सेंड टू द ईमेल आफ्टर अ फ्यू मोमेंट्स
आई रिसीवड एन ईमेल कंटेनिंग द कॉपी ऑफ माय
चैट द पेलोड वाज एक्टिवेटेड व्हेन आई ओपें
द ईमेल आई क्विकली क्रिएटेडटेड द नेक्स्ट
मॉर्निंग आई रिसीवड अ ट्राक रिस्पांस बस
सिंपल सा किया भाई बाउ मिली बाउंटीज नहीं
नहीं मिला बाउंट मिली सिंपल सा चैट में
इन्होंने पेल डाला और वो एक ईमेल रिपोर्ट
मंगा ली चैट की ट्रांसक्रिप्ट जिसको बोलते
हैं और उसमें उनका पेरोड एग्जीक्यूट कर
गया इंपैक्ट इंपैक्ट क्या होता है देखो
यहां पे एज द ईमेल इज कमिंग डायरेक्टली
फ्रॉम द कंपनी एन अटैकर कुड एंटर एनी वनस
ईमेल एड्रेस टू रिसीव दिस टाइप ऑफ ईमेल्स
व्हिच मे कंटेंस मलसियन और फिशिंग लिंक्स
व्हिच कुड लीड टू यूजर्स बीइंग ट्रिक इनटू
गिविंग लॉगइन इंफॉर्मेशन टू अटैक अस इसका
ये इंपैक्ट था सिंपल सा फिशिंग ईमेल फिश
आप हो सकते हो फिशिंग के हो सकते हो
बेसिकली बाद में आप इसको चेन अप करके
एक्सएसएस में भी चेन अप कर सकते हो एंड यू
कैन जस्ट ट्राई इट आउट राइट ठीक है अब
देखिए
य यह तो चलिए ये तो ठीक है एक इनको मिला
और कोई मिला है क्या किसी
को ये क्या
भाई ये एटील इंजेक्शन 600 का है समझ में आ
रहा है और ये 2021 का ही है बहुत पुराना
भी नहीं है चलो
क्या किया इन्होने अरे भाई चलो ये करना
पड़ेगा
हमें एचटीएमएल को एसस आरफ में भी आप वो कर
सकते हो बेसिकली चेन अप कर सकते हो ए
नेक्स्ट क्लाउड गट बाउंट 500 क्या बात है
00 मिला है चलो हैकर वन का ही मैं आपको
दिखाता हूं एटी
इंजेक्शन
हैकर वन पर चलते हैं भैया एंड यहां पर कुछ
रिपोर्ट्स ओपन कर लेते हैं एटी इंजेक्शन
के ठीक है देखो ए इंजेक्शन का इंपैक्ट मैं
आपको सिंपल सा यहां पर बताना चाहता हूं
ठीक है यहां
पर
इंपैक्ट ऑफ एचटीएमएल इंजेक्शन ठीक है यह
मैं आपको दिखाता
हूं पहले क्या हो सकता है फिशिंग आप कर
सकते हैं इससे फिशिंग हो सकती है फिशिंग
टेक्निक यूज करती है कैन बी चें टू
एक्सेसेस और इवन
एसएसआरएफ इस पे भी आप कर सकते हैं अकाउंट
टेक ओवर तक आप इसको चेन अप भी कर सकते हैं
ट्राई आउट मार सकते हैं चेचेन अप जितना
चेन अप करने का तो ये चेंज हो सकता है
एक्सस में तो ये ज्यादा
सीविरियस
निशन हो सकती
है ठीक है इस तरीके की चीज हो सकती है
इसके मल्टीपल वो है अब यहां पे एक काम
करते
हैं वी आर गोइंग टू डू ए इंजेक्शन ये ओपन
कर ये ओपन कर
य ओपन कर लेते हैं अजय गरेवाल वेलकम ब्रदर
ओपन कर लेते हैं य ओपन कर लेते हैं देखो
कुछ को कुछ मिला है देखते हैं
य चलिए य ओपन हो रही है हैकर वन की इनको
कुछ बाउंट टी मिली है
क्या इनको कोई बाउंट तो य मुझे कुछ दिख
नहीं रही आई एम गुर की है ये
ओल्डर एक्टिविटी चेक कर लेते एक
बार ठीक है देखो सम समझ सिंपल सा क्या
किया गो टू दिस वेबसाइट एंड यू विल सी
एक्सटर्नल वीडियोस ठीक है ना नोट ट दिस
टेस्ट पेज अटैकर मोर यूजर यहां प क्या कर
रहा है रिमेंबर ल यहां पे एंड यहां प जाने
के बाद बाद यहां पे evil.com को
रीडायरेक्ट कर रहा है सिंपल सा ये फंडा है
ये सिंपल सा है हटाओ
इसको यहां पे स्टील इंजेक्शन हो रही है
एंड इफ ही गॉट एनी
बाउंटीज मिल गई है चलो यहां पे ऑटोमेटिक
रिवॉर्ड अ इनको विथ अ बाउंट तो बाउंट मिली
है 2022 की एसटीएल इंजेक्शन रिपोर्टेड कि
रिपोर्ट किया इन्होंने व्हाट यही हैव डन
आई फाउंड दैट द सर्च बॉक्स ऑन प्रेसेबल कॉ
इज वल्नरेबल फॉर एक्सेसेस अटैक एंड
एसटीएमएल इंजेक्शन स्टेप्स टू रीप्रोड्यूस
क्या है यहां पे सिंपल सा ची चीज है यहां
पे देखिए यहां
पे विजिट दिस वन पुट द पेलोड ऑन द सर्च
बॉक्स ये पेलोड डाल दिया एक्सस का पेलोड
यहां पे डाल दिया ये वाली पेलोड यहां पे
एक्सस की डाल दी एटीएल इंजेक्शन पेलोड
यहां पे डाला है ये वाला एटीएल इंजेक्शन
का पेलोड है यहां पे जो यहां पे ये डाला
हुई है एक्सेसेस विल ट्रगल एटीएल इंजेक्शन
विल बी रिफ्लेक्टेड सिंपल सा फंडा है
एचटीएमएल आपका रिफ्लेक्ट हो जाएगा और
एक्सेसेस जो है आपका ट्रिगर हो जाएगा तो
ये पेलोड यहां पे जैसे इस तरीके से पेलोड
यहां पे है ये यहां पे कॉपी किया यहां पे
और जैसे आपका पेलोड है जिस भी वेबसाइट में
आपको डालना है जो भी आपका टारगेट है उसमें
आपको यहां पे डाल देना है जैसे कि मैं
यहां पे बैक कर देता हूं जैसे ये हमारा
टारगेट हो गया मान लो लेट्स सपोज जस्ट गिव
एन एग्जांपल यहां पे और यहां पे हम एंटर
करते हैं तो अगर यहां पे हमें ये
रिफ्लेक्ट होता हुआ मिल रहा है यहां पे ये
सिंपल सा क्लीकेबल अगर एच आर फ
क्लिकब्रिक्स
जहां एटील इंजेक्शन है वहां एक्सस के लिए
ट्राई कर सकते हो एक्सस के पेलो डाल सकते
हो चेन अप करने की कोशिश कर सकते हो एंड
यू कैन बी गेटिंग द एक्सस आल्सो ठीक है बस
सिंपल सा इंपैक्ट क्या है ड्यू टू दिस
वनबिल अटैक कैन इजली डाइवर्ट विक्टिम्स टू
देयर मालीशियस साइट एंड एबल टू गेट
क्रेडेंशियल ऑफ द विक्टिम्स तो इसमें आप
एक चीज ऐड कर लो यहां पे ओपन रीडायरेक्शन
या सीधा ओपन रीडायरेक्शन नहीं बोलेंगे
रीडायरेक्टिंग
यूजर्स टू मशियल
वेबसाइट्स ठीक है य इंपैक्ट का एक य पैक्ट
भी हो गया फिशिंग हो गई कैन ब चें
चें चन
टू एक्सस और न एसस आरफ इननेशन हो जाएगी
एंड रीडायरेक्ट आप कर सकते हो उसको तो
यहां पर इनको बांटी मिली हुई है चलिए अब य
पर चलते माय क्रिप्टो प ही गट एनी
बाउंट इसको बाउंट तो नहीं मिली है ब ट्रग
हुई है य ट्रैग हुई है ठीक है सर आज मे
बडे है अरे हैप्पी बर्थडे यार हैप्पी
बर्थडे हैप्पी बर्थडे
ब्रदर सर आपका गौरव चौधरी के साथ क्या
मैटर हुआ कौन सा गौरव चौधरी भाई मैं गौरव
चौधरी जैसा कोई जानता भी नहीं मैटर क्या
होगा यार मेरा कोई कोई कनेक्शन ही नहीं है
इसी
किसी टेक्निकल गुरुजी की बात कर रहे हो
क्या मेरी टे टेक्निकल गुरु जी से क्या
होगी हैप्पी बर्थडे ब्रदर तो यहां पे
इन्होंने क्या किया सिंपल सा यहां पे हेलो
आई रिमें कपल ऑफ मंस आई फाउंड स् वडी और
यहां पे क्या किया इन्होंने सिंपल माइक गए
सिपल पॉप अप करा लिया ये वाले मैथ ये वाला
जो पलट था उसे पॉप अप करा लिया एंड
दैट्ची नेम फील्ड से यह आपकी जो है एटी
इंजेक्शन जो है वो पॉसिबल हो पा रही है
देखो क्या हुआ आई वुड लाइक टू रिपोर्ट एन
इशू विद वेर अटैकर्स इ एबल टू इंजेक्ट एटी
इनटू द नेम फील्ड एट डफडे समझ में आ रहा
है अब यहां देखो ध्यान दो यहां पे ध्यान
दो रजिस्टर किया इस पे इंजेक्ट नेम फीड
विथ एनी एटील पोर्ट जैसे हमने यहां पे
किया ना अपने टारगेट में इंजेक्ट किया
था इस वाले टारगेट में हमने सिंपल सा जब
हम बाय करने जा रहे थे परचेस करने जा रहे
थे तो हमने नेम फील्ड में ही इंजेक्ट किया
था वैसे ही सेम यहां पे हो रहा है ओपन द
टम्स टेस्ट ईमेल एचटीएमएल विल बी
एग्जीक्यूटेड तो हमने मेल में जो मेल आया
था उसमें हमने देखा था जो हमें मेल आई थी
यहां पे यह मेल आई थी तो यहां पे य
एसटीएमएल आया था एंड वहां पे एटीएमएल
एग्जीक्यूट हो रहा है देखो बस सिंपल सा
फंड है यही चीज है थैंक यू फॉर सबमिशन आई
होप यू आर वेल योर रिपोर्ट इज करेंटली
रिव्यूड एंड यहां पे एक लो है ठीक है थैंक
यू सबमिशन वी हैव सबमिटेड
एप्रोप्रियेट नहीं है अब उसके बाद इस बंदे
ने बोला डोंट लेट यूजर्स गेट पंड वाय
एचटीएमएल
इंजेक्शन ईमेल एटीएल इंजेक्शन एटीएल
इंजेक्शन इन टू ईमेल इज डेंजरस योर यूजर्स
आर एट रिस्क व्हेन अ हैकर इज एबल टू टेक
कंट्रोल ऑफ द ईमेल्स ठीक है दैट योर
एप्लीकेशन सेंड समझ में आ रहा है व्ट बट
व्हाट्स स्पेसिफिकली डेंजरस इज दैट ईमेल्स
विल बी कमिंग फ्रॉम योर कंपनी ईमेल एड्रेस
कंपनी के ईमेल एड्रेस से वो मेल आ रही है
ठीक है सबसे पहली चीज व्हेन अ मलिस ईमेल
कम्स फ्रॉम यो कंपनी ईमेल इट लुक्स अ लॉट
मोर लेज लेमेट ये सही बात है लेजिटीमेट
लगती है लगती है कि भाई कंपनी ही ईमेल भेज
रही है तो वहां इंपर्सनेशन होने के चांसेस
होते हैं और यूजर्स को लगता है यह तो भाई
कंपनी का है तो ट्रस्ट कर देते हैं उस परे
क्लिक कर देते हैं इससे बड़ा अटैक लंच
किया सकता है हाउ टू प्रिवेंट एचटीएमएल
इंजेक्शन यहां पे इन्होंने दे रखा है उसके
बाद इन्होंने रिओपन किया इस रिपोर्ट को
एंड यहां पे इसको ट्रैग कर दिया ट्रैग
करने के बाद $500 की बाउंट भी दे दी एंड
उसके बाद इन्होंने इसको फिक्स कर दिया
देखो यहां पे पहले इस बंदे ने यहां पे
दिया है यहां पे आई थिंक इसका कोई इमेज
नहीं है ना ये तो वीडियो फाइल है इमेज
नहीं है तो छोड़िए यहां पे बाद में
इन्होंने यहां पे दिखाया है कि यहां पे ये
जो है ये बेसिकली क्या है फिक्स हो चुकी
है अब यहां पे ये
क्लिकब्रिक्स
की बाउंट मिलेगी एटीएमएल इंजेक्शन की भी
एंड अगर कुछ इस तरीके का आप निकाल लेते
हैं जैसे आप ईमेल आप जैसे आपने ईमेल किया
यहां पे ये रिफ्लेक्ट हो रही है ये विजिट
डि फोनिक्स ऐसे करके क्लिक होके एंड यहां
पे एटीएमएल इंजेक्ट हो रहा है तो दिस वन
इज मोर इंपैक्टफुल देन अ सिंपल रिफ्लेक्शन
ऑन क्लाइंट साइड वो एक सिंपल रिफ्लेक्शन
जो हो रही है उससे ज्यादा इंपैक्टफुल ये
होगा इसमें आपको बाउंट मिलने के चांसेस
बहुत ज्यादा बढ़ जाते हैं बहुत ज्यादा
ह्यूज बढ़ जाते हैं ये बात याद रखिएगा
क्योंकि ये मेल ऑफिशियल इस वेबसाइट से आ
रही है हमारे पास इस वेबसाइट से और इसमें
हमने क्या किया क्योंकि ये वेबसाइट से आ
रही है तो भैया अब इसमें जो लिंक आ रही है
इसपे कोई भी मैं ट्रस्ट करूंगा क्योंकि
मेरे को तो ऑफिशियल मेल आ रहा है ये मेरे
को एज अ यूजर यह तो ऑफिशियल मेल आ रहा है
तो मैं तो इस पर ट्रस्ट करूंगा इसमें कुछ
भी हो सकता है विज de.com के जगह पे कोई
एक मशियल यूआरएल हो सकती है मैं उस पर चला
जाऊंगा व फिशिंग यूआरएल होगी ट्स इट डन
सिंपल सा इस तरीके सी चीजें आपकी यह काम
करती है यह बात यह एस इंजेक्शन समझ में
आया आपको बढ़िया से बता दीजिए मुझे सभी को
थोड़ा तड़ा केदार बड़ा केदार समझ में
आई सभी लोग बताइए भाई साहब नहीं बताओगे तो
कैसे काम चलेगा यार बताओ ना सभी को समझ
में आया जल्दी
बताओ अब समझ में आया इसका क्या इंपैक्ट हो
सकता है भैया इंपैक्ट समझ में आया
आपको कि नहीं आया अभी
भी नहीं सभी लोग नहीं बोलोगे तो काम नहीं
चलेगा भाई एक बोल रहा है यार बंदा सेफ नेट
वाला मजा आया
ए फाइंड करना शुरू कर दो भाई ओके ओके
माफिया निशांत इट्स द
तान्या और भाई जो लोग यहां पर ऐसे लोग जो
काफी काफी
ज्यादा एंथिया है बग बांटी को लेकर काफी
ज्यादा एक्साइटेड रहते हैं और जिन्होंने ट
ग्रुप जवाइन किया था बट कुछ लोगों ने लीव
कर दिया था तो आप दोबारा से जवाइन कर
लीजिएगा ठीक है ना या हमें मैसेज कर
लीजिएगा वापस से आपको ऐड कर देंगे
कुछ असामाजिक तत्व के कारण आपने लीव किया
था तो आप जवाइन कीजिएगा क्योंकि अच्छे
लोगों की रिक्वायरमेंट है ठीक
है ओके यस यस
यस कोर्स कौन सा कोर्स भाई हमारा तो
हैकिंग का कोर्स
है यस
बहुत कोर्स कितना का दे रहे हैं अरे भाई
कोर्स हमारा यार एथिकल हैकिंग का कोर्स है
कंप्लीट अगर आपको इसकी डिटेल चाहिए तो मैं
लिंक डाल देता हूं यहां पर
आप इस पर जाके एंड डिटेल चेक आउट कर सकते
हैं हमारे कोर्स की लिंक को पिन कर दिया
मैंने मौज कर दी भैया धन्यवाद अब बताओ यार
लाइव में मजा आ रहा है कि नहीं मजा आ रहा
लाइव में तुम लोग आते नहीं
हो यस सर मजा भी आया समझ भी चलो धन्यवाद
भाई यह ब्रेव गेमिंग कौन हो यार नाम तुम
लोग नहीं रखते हो नाम नहीं रखते हो मजा
नहीं आता सच में नाम से आया करो ना मुझे
भी पता चले कौन है क्या है ब्रेव गेमिंग
कौन है साइबर कौन
है वेबसाइट डिफेसिंग पर वीडियो बनाओ आ
जाएगी भाई टेंशन मत लो सब आएगा टेंशन लेने
से नहीं होगा एक एक करके सब
आएगा ठीक है एक एक करके सब आएगा चलो यह तो
हमने एक लाइव वेबसाइट प हमने ट्राई आउट
किया बहुत मजा आया
ओके
कौन सा कहां पर रिपोर्ट किया सेफ नेट भाई
बताइए कहां पर रिपोर्ट
किया वैभ पटेल यर ओके आईम फ्रॉम पाकिस्तान
य स्टूडेंट ओके साइबर हंटर एक्स
ग्रेट व ग्रुप लिंक डिस्क्रिप्शन में इसी
वीडियो के डिस्क्रिप्शन में
देखिएगा ट ग्रुप चालू हो चुका फिर से
मैंने कर दिया है आएंगे भाई सीटीएफ डीफ सब
आएंगे टेंशन नहीं लेने का डीसी जीएसपी
स्टूडेंट
ओके तो वहां पे सही से प्रॉपर्ली रिपोर्ट
नहीं किया होगा आपने सेफ नेट जी इसलिए हो
सकता है प्रॉपर्ली रिपोर्ट कीजिएगा तो
माइट बी वो माइट बी वो एक्सेप्ट हो
जाएगी अच्छा यहां पे पॉसिबल एक्सेसेस है
यहां पे यह वाली चीज में यहां पे क्या आ
रहा है
पॉसिबल इसको रिमूव कर देते हैं एटीए
इंजेक्शन में यहां पे ये कौन सी रिपोर्ट
है
भाई
देख लेते
हैं ये तो वही
है यह एक लोकल ट टोपी लोवा जो भी है यार
इस पर आ
जाओ यहां पर एक एटील इंजेक्शन के 64 बाउंट
लगे हैं भाई और भाई को 16 में लगे हैं
लेकिन गजब भी बाउंट है
64 क्या किया ओपन लिंक ये सेट एटमी ये
लिंक एच आरएफ यूज किया सेट इतना टू
विक्टिम ईमेल एंड सबमिट फॉर्म ये जो फॉर्म
होती है ना सब्सक्राइबर फॉर्म उसमें डाल
के डाल दिया है सही है यह भी सही है
यार एटी
इंजेक्शन ये कौन सी है भैया बाउंट लगी है
क्या इनको ट्रैग हो गया रिजॉल्व हो गया
बाउंट तो इनको हॉल ऑफ फेम दिया है यहां पे
हॉल ऑफ फेम दिया इनको तो क्या किया यहां
पर आई हैव फाउंड एसटीएल इंजेक्शन ऑन दिस
डोमेन पैरामीटर इंजेक्टबल इज एचटीएमएल
क्वेश्चन मार्क q = 1 q इव यहां पर
एचटीएमएल को एचटीएमएल डाल दिया यहां पे
इन्होंने इसको इनकोड कर दिया है कहने का
मतलब दे हैव इनकोडेड एंड यहां प पेलोड
यहां प यह वाला पेलोड यूज कर लिया है
अच्छी बात है यहां पे इंपैक्ट क्या फिशिंग
एब्यूज अदर यूजर डिफेसिंग यही सब चीज होती
है बस यह चीज कर दिया ट्स इट चलिए हम एक
और टारगेट ले लेते
हैं इसी बात प वी आर गोइंग टू टेक अनदर
टारगेट एक तो हमने देखा भी करके हो गया
यार सर जी आई एम फ्रॉम बलूचिस्तान माय नेम
इज मोहम्मद कासिम ओके कासिम
बढ़िया आ जाते हैं यहां पे कोई से भी एक
टारगेट ऑल प्रोग्राम देख लेते हैं
रिसेंटली स्टार्टेड में यह सारे हैं तो
विता दू क्या है ये इसको देखते हैं क्या
है भा है
चलो ओपन कर लेते हैं इसको इसी को
सीच वीटा वेडू ड
सीए थैंक यू सो मच स्वीट ब्रदर सर ओ हो
क्या बात है
भाई
ट्रांसलेट कर दिया हमने अच्छा यहां पर तो
पूरा का पूरा यह है अच्छी बात है य पर मैं
य पर इसको भी क्रम में ओपन करना चाहूंगा
लेट्स ओपन इन
क्रोम लेटस ओपन इन
कम इंग्लिश में कन्वर्ट करते हैं ऑलवेज
ट्रांसलेट करते हैं लवेज ट्रांसलेट फ्रेंच
ठीक है ी आर इनटू द कम यहां पर हमें
रिजल्ट मिल रहा है डिक्स लिखते हैं एंटर
करते हैं हां जी डिलोनिक्स
रिफ्लेक्ट हो रही है
h1 डि
फोनिक्स h1 क्लोज कर देते
हैं ठीक
[संगीत]
है आई वांट टू स्विच माय करियर इन पबजी
नीड पर्सन रोड मैप पबज में करियर स्विच
करना है तो पहले तो इस लाइव से तुम चले
जाओ अच्छा यहां पर यहां पे वफ लगा हुआ है
सो इट्स गेटिंग बायपास कंट्रोल यू करके
यहां प अगर देखते हैं डि फोनिक्स सो
ओबवियसली इट इज जस्ट इट
इज सैनिटाइजिंग मतलब यहां पे बेसिकली वफ
लगा हुआ है नथिंग एल्स तो इसको अभी ऐसे
रहने देते हैं लेट्स सी लेट्स डू वन थिंग
लेट्स चूज सम
अदर चलो अ
ऑल बक बाउटी
प्रोग्राम्स सर आप बहुत ही अच्छा पढ़ाते
हो आफ्टर लॉट सर्च करने के बाद आपका
मैं आपको बता रहा हूं ट्राई टू
एस्केलेट या चेन एचटीएमएल इंजेक्शन टू
एक्सेसेस और अदर
हाई
सिरिटी वल्नरेबल
ठीक है यह आपको करना है यही आपका मेन
मोटिव होना चाहिए ठीक
है मेन मोटिव यही होना चाहिए ट इट अरे
रिप्लाई कर दिया ओ भाई
रेडी कि पबजी अगर में करियर बनाना है तो
यह वाला स्ट्रीम छोड़ के पबजी में घुस आप
पबजी की स्ट्रीम
देखिए इतना अगर टाइम लगेगा तो मैं इसमें
करूंगा क्यों मैं यहां प ओपन कर लूंगा
सिंपल ठीक
है ओके गट इट दिस वास
अब जाओ सारी वेबसाइट्स में एज अ प्रैक्टिस
एटीएल इंजेक्शन फाइंड करने की कोशिश करो
जो रिफ्लेक्ट हो रहा है ना सामने एटीएमएल
का टैग एटीएमएल इंजेक्शन है उसको ट्राई
करो थोड़ा
सवेरियो बनाने की इंपैक्टफुल बनाने की अगर
वो इंपैक्टफुल होता है किसी एक पर्टिकुलर
नेम पैरामीटर में कहीं स्टोर्ड हो रहा है
जाके स्टोर्ड एचटीएमएल इंजेक्शन हो रहा है
जैसे स्टोर्ड एक्सेसेस होता है ना अगर
स्टोर्ड एचटीएमएल इंजेक्शन तुमने फाइंड
किया जैसे हमने हमारे टारगेट पे फाइंड
किया था हमने कौन से टारगेट पे फाइंड किया
था हमने ये वाला bap.com इस पे हमने जो
फाइंड किया था अगर सेम चीज अगर तुम फाइंड
कर पा रहे हो जैसे हमने यहां पे मेल में
यहां पे ये चीज करा ली थी तो ये
इंपैक्टफुल होता है एंड यू कैन रिपोर्ट इट
एंड यू विल गेट अमाउंट सीधा-सीधा बात है
तो जाइए फाइंड कीजिए यहां पे अभी ये ओपन
भी नहीं हो रहा है तो कोई बात नहीं इस
इसको रहने देते हैं कोई टेंशन नहीं है
ज्यादा टेंशन नहीं लेना का ठीक है तो आई
होप कि आपको एचटीएमएल इंजेक्शन सबको बहुत
क्लियर हो गया होगा एवरीवन इज एब्सलूट
क्लियर अबाउट एचटीएमएल इंजेक्शन कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं आ रही है सबको क्लियर हो
गया
भाई बता दीजिए एक बार जल्दी
से
अरे लिखते हो तुम
पबजी अच्छा बग बाउटी है क्या आई वांट टू
स्विच मा करियर इन बग बांटी नीड पस रोड
मैप अरे भैया रोड मैप का मैंने ऑलरेडी
जैसे है ना
एक यह जो हमारी बग बांटी की सीरीज चल रही
है इसको बस शुरू से फॉलो करो डे वन से वही
रोड मैप है तुम्हारा फिलहाल के लिए ठीक
है ऑल क्लियर ऑल क्लियर बहुत बढ़िया
क्लियर हो गया बहुत सिंपल सा था एचटीएमएल
इंजेक्शन यार ज्यादा कुछ नहीं था बहुत
सिंपल सा है थोड़ा सा दिमाग अब लगाओगे
एक्सप्लोर करोगे मैंने बोला ना जितना
कराता हूं उससे ज्यादा एक्सप्लोर नहीं
किया ना तो कोई फायदा नहीं है मेरा सब
कारना बेकार हो जाएगा एक वनबिल जब मैं
बताऊं उसको भैया अगले दो-तीन दिन
एक्सप्लोर करो रिवाइज करो प्रैक्टिस करो
दोबारा वीडियो देखो नोट्स बनाओ उसके
अलग-अलग टाइप की चीजों को प्रैक्टिस करो
टारगेट पे रियल टारगेट पे ट्राई करो ठीक
है लैब्स को सॉल्व करो इतना करो 100% यू
विल बिकम परफेक्ट इन दैट पर्टिकुलर वन एक
एक लेबिलिटी को लेके चलो अब एसटी इंजेक्शन
पढ़ा सब पे ही ट्राई करो एसस आरफ पढ़ा
पढ़ोगे उसी प ट्राई करो एक्सेस पढ़ा उसको
ट्राई ऐसे करके चलो ठीक
है गट इट
गाइस
बढ़िया एज आई सेड योर एक्सप्लेनेशन इज फार
बेटर देन आवर मैथ टीचर थैंक यू भाई
धन्यवाद धन्यवाद धन्यवाद थैंक यू सो
मच और तुम लोगों ने यार मैंने क्लीन शेव
करा तुम लोगों ने यार सबने बहुत बुरा बुरा
बोला मुझे सर क्लीन से अच्छा नहीं लगता
चलो अब आ रही है थोड़ी बहुत ड तो अब थोड़ा
शायद सही
लगे तुम लोग दो मिनट में यार बेज्जती कर
देते हो सब किसी की भी
सब स्क्रीनशॉट लेनी है नोट्स क्या है यार
नोट्स तो कुछ था ही नहीं नोट्स भी है क्या
नोट्स भी बनते हैं क्या यही है नोट्स कहां
था कुछ यही था यह था एक सिंपल सा इस तरीके
का स्क्रीनशॉट ले लो अगर लेना है तो उसके
बाद एक यह था
एकदम आज का क्लास पता नहीं चला इतने स्मूथ
था क् लाइव में तुम्हें कुछ मिला ना बस
वही चीज है ठीक है चलिए
सो थोड़ी चैटिंग करते हैं अरे वाह यार
थोड़ी चैटिंग करते हैं चैटिंग करने का मन
हो रहा है इस भाई साहब को चलो चलो ठीक है
जब तुमने बोला तो थोड़ी चैटिंग कर लेते
हैं हां जी
बताइए
सब सब लोग डार्क वेब से इंस्टॉल हुआ ये
क्या बोल रहा है भाई
पल सही बात है क्लीन से अच्छा लता चलो ठीक
है भाई ध्यान रखूंगा नेक्स्ट टाइम से
धन्यवाद आपके फीडबैक के
लिए पाकिस्तान में कोई इंस्ट्रक्टर ऐसा
नहीं सिखाया चलो अच्छी बात है साइबर हंटर
एक्स अगर आपको यह अच्छी लग रही है एंड
आपको यह पढ़ाने का तरीका अच्छा लग रहा है
आपको समझ में आ रहा है सो इट्स वेरी मच
प्राउड थिंग फॉर मी आल्सो फर नक्स अकेडमी
डि फनिक साइबर सिक्योरिटी आल्सो कि आपको
सीखने को मिल रहा है ठीक है आप इंडिया के
हो पाकिस्तान के हो बांग्लादेश के हो
नेपाल के हो आसपास के हमारे जो भी कंट्रीज
के हो या कहीं के भी हो उससे कोई फर्क
नहीं पड़ता है लर्निंग इ ए नॉलेज इ फॉर
एवरीवन नॉलेज सबके लिए होता है एंड मैं
सबको पढ़ाता हूं सबको सिखाता हूं किसी एक
पर्टिकुलर बंदे को किसी एक पर्टिकुलर
कंट्री को नहीं सिखाता हूं
मैं ठीक
है क्लास आएगा क्या बड़ा खुश हो या डार्क
क्लास सर थैंक यू आज के क्लास के लिए थैंक
यू वेलकम
वेलकम सर ओके सर मैं आईटी बैकग्राउंड से
नहीं हूं नेटवर्क और नेटवर्क का भी जीरो
नॉलेज कोई बात नहीं या प्रैक्टिस करते रहो
ना आईटी बैकग्राउंड क्या ही कर लेगा
प्रैक्टिस करते रहो अभी अभी मैं अपने बारे
में तो खुलासा करूंगा आने वाले कुछ टाइम
बाद तुम लोग शौक हो जाओगे तुम लोगों की
ऐसी हालत किसी की नहीं होगी मेरे ख्याल से
तो तुम लोग कुछ नहीं अभी तो बहुत कुछ कर
चुके हो तुम लोग यार तुम लोग की अच्छी है
सब कुछ सच
है तो अभी मेरे बारे में तो कुछ किसी को
पता ही नहीं है जो खुलासा होगा बाद में
बाद में होगा अभी तो नहीं
होगा सर जी नेक्स्ट 200 नेक्स्ट बार 200
पार 200 लाइव में तुम लोग आओगे इतनी इतनी
वो तो तुम लोग नहीं दिखाओगे 200 आ गए तब
तो भाई समझ
लो चलो एक चीज बताता हूं एक चीज देता हू
अगर तुम लोग नेक्स्ट लाइव में नेक्स्ट
क्लास में 200 लाइव आ गए 200 लोग आए तो
उसका आपको
एक कुछ सरप्राइज मिलेगा आपको गिफ्ट मिलेगा
सरप्राइज आप लोगों के लिए एक सरप्राइज फिर
मैं लेकर आऊंगा आप लोग केलिए ठीक अगर दो आ
जाते हो लाइ सच बता रहा आप लोगों को कुछ
सरप्राइज दूंगा आई विल गिव यू सम
सरप्राइज थैंक यू थैंक यू
ब्रदर पहली बार लाइव आए हो क्यों यार भाई
डेली आया
करो सर जो दिल में दिल मन में दिल मन है
वही जवान पर होना चाहिए हां सही बात है
बिल्कुल सही बात है किस बारे में बोल र हो
यह तो समझा ही नहीं मतलब क्यों बोल रहे हो
यह थॉट था कि क्या
था यो वा ग्रेट थैंक यू तेजेश थैंक यू
ब्रदर सर मैंने एक साइट में एक्सस फाइंड
करा उसमें स्क्रिप्ट इसका बाद जो मैंने
नेक्स्ट स्क्रिप्ट लगा रहा हूं वो नॉट
वर्किंग बट एचटीएमएल इज वर्किंग लाइक ए
टैग डैग बट नॉट शोइंग ऑल अलर्ट मैसेज
जरूरी नहीं है ना यार शो ही करेगा बहुत
तरह की फिल्ट्रेशन सैनिटाइजेशन लगी होती
है तो उसको बायपास करो ट्राई करो वफ होता
है उसको बायपास
करो नहीं नहीं सर थोड़ा बहुत जानता हूं
आपके स्ट्रगल के बारे में यस शमीम बट एक
चीज है जो किसी को नहीं पता है वो मैंने
हालाकि बताया ही नहीं है पब्लिक डोमेन में
है ही नहीं बट वो मैं लाऊंगा कभी जब मुझे
फील होगा कि आई शुड ब्रिंग
दैट तो आई विल बी ब्रिंगिंग ट वो बहुत
ह्यूज चीज है बहुत यूज ह्यूज है वो नो वन
कैन थिंक ऑफ
दैट
सर मैंने एक वेबसाइट में प्राइस
मैनिपुलेशन ओटीपी बायपास किया उसका बग
बाउटी प्रोग्राम ही नहीं है तो मोए मोए
वाली बात हो गई
भाई मो मोए
बात एसकल मै आप से क्लियर टेक्स्ट में
पासवर्ड देख सकते क्या अरे भाई तो इनकोडेड
इनक्रिप्टेड होगा तो कहां से देखोगे उसको
डिक्रिप्ट करोगे तो देखोगे इनक्रिप्टेड
नहीं होगा प्लेन टेक्स्ट में होगा तो देख
लोगे आ जाएगी
आएगी फिर
तो 200 चलो अच्छी बात है या थैंक यू
भाई अबकी बार 400 पार अब इतना भी मत बोलो
200 आ जाएगा वही आंखों में आंसू आ जाएंगे
फिर
तो एंड्र पन टेस्ट कोर्स के बारे में बताओ
जल्दी लंच कर रहे जल्दी लच कर रहे टेंशन
ना लेने न वन ईयर इ नफ फर करियर इन बग
बांटी मुझे तो लगता है छ महीना ही काफी है
बग बांटी में करियर बनाने के लिए लिटरली
बट वन ईयर तो बहुत ज्यादा हो गया न ईयर
में तो तुम फो डालोगे एकदम तहलका मचा दोगे
न ईयर में बस ना ल
ल कौन-कौन सी बग के बारे बग के ऊपर
कौन-कौन सी वलने बिलिटी के ऊपर क्लास और
चाहिए तुम्हें बताओ मुझे चैट में बताओ
देखते हैं किसको किस किस व बिलिटी के बारे
में पता है क्या है कौन-कौन सी व बिलिटी
की और क्लासेस आपको चाहिए
नेपाल ओ नेपाल भाई क्या हाल है नेपाल से
हो क्या तुम तो यार पास के हो हमारे यहां
से जहां पर मैं अभी हूं वहां से नेपाल का
नेपाल का जो डिस्टेंस है व न ए हाफ आर का
है जी हा 90 मिनट्स का डेढ़ घंटे
का दाढ़ी वाली बात प धन्यवाद
भाई हा वही तो य इलेक्शन वाली बात बोल रहा
है अकी बार 400
पर
ओ
भाई एसकल इंजेक्शन ब्लाइंड एसकल आई एक्सेस
कंट्रोल रिमोट कोड एग्जीक्यूशन
क्रिप्टोग्राफिक फेलियर इनसिक्योर
डायरेक्ट ऑब्जेक्ट रेफर य देखो आईडी बोल
रहा भाई आईडी की मैंने नहीं बनाई वीडियो
आईडी के ऊपर पूरी क्लास ली है यार तुम बोल
रहे आईडी की क्लास लो यह तो भाई गलत बात
है तुम लोग क्लास नहीं देखते क्या अरे भाई
आईडी की ऑलरेडी क्लास हो चुकी है माफिया
भाई माफिया गिरी छोड़ के आओ तो बक बांटी
में माफिया गिरी कर रहे हो
तुम एपीआई पेन टेस्टिंग आएगी भाई टेंशन ना
लो एसीडीपी रिक्वेस्ट स्मगलिंग ठीक है
ब्रोकन एक्सेस
कंट्रोल ब्रोकेन कुछ चीजें मैंने कवर की
है वैसे बट ठीक है देखते हैं ओडीबी बायपास
थैंक यू सो मच गेमर ऑफ तुषार वेलकम ब्रदर
वेबसाइट डिफिंग डीडीओएस डीडीओएस तो क्या
करोगे यार हद है डीडीओएस क्या कोई करने
वाली लेबिलिटी सीखने वाली चीज
है ए ग्राफ कल ठीक है फाइल इंक्लूजन हां
एलएफ आई एलएफ आई और आरएफ आई रिमोट फाइल
इंक्लूजन एंड लोकल फाइल इंक्लूजन ये भी
आएगी एसर भी आएगी डोंट वरी एल इंजेक्शन तो
आएगा ही
आएगा बॉब शूट का क्रैक कहां मिलेगा अरे सब
मिलेगा टेंशन ना लेने
का हां जब कोई कंपनी का वक बाउंट
प्रोग्राम ना हो तो रि फ्रेन फ्रॉम
रिपोर्टिंग देम उस पर हंट करना भी बेकार
है मेरे ख्याल से व आप अपने टेस्टिंग के
लिए अपने अपने कैपेबिलिटी को टेस्ट करने
के लिए और अपने प्रैक्टिसेस के लिए हंट कर
सकते हो बट स्टिल आई आई विल से की लीगली
सही नहीं है अगर उनका बग बांटी प्रोग्राम
नहीं है तो दे आर नॉट गिविंग यू परमिशन टू
हंट न देम तो यू शुड रिफ एंड आपको उसी
प्रोग्राम प जाना चाहिए जिनका बग बांटी या
या वीडीपी है या रिस्पांसिबल डिस्क्लोजर
प्रोग्राम है
कोई मतलब डिस्क्लोजर प्रोग्राम है कोई
बांटी है या वीडीपी चल रहा है
तो ठीक है स टॉप 10 में सारा करा दो ठीक
है भाई कराएंगे
इजी पीटी के लिए कोई वाइटी चैनल रिकमेंड
कर दो यह तो मैं नहीं जानता यार मैं
रिकमेंड कैसे करूं आई कांट
से आज तो यार आप लोग की प्रेजेंस देख के
पता नहीं क्यों मजा आ रहा है मुझे ऐसे ही
रहना यार सारे लाइव में तभी तो यार अंदर
से हो जाएगी मजे से
फाइल अपलोड टी ठीक है भाई फाइल अपलोड भी
आएगी जेडब्ल्यूडी टोकन बाय पास
ओके बिजनेस लॉजिक लेबिलिटी ओके पाथ ा
वर्सल कैन य एक्सप्लेन ल लिटी एक वीडियो
में बहुत लंबा वीडियो वैसे हो जाएगा बट
ठीक है देखते
हैं डायरेक्ट लिस्टिंग ठीक
है इतनी अच्छी पढ़ाई फिर भी लाइक 27 बहुत
नाइस आप 27 ही लाइ अरे ऐसा कैसे हो सकता
है 181 लाइक है
भाई बोल यार इनसिक्योर क्रिप्टोग्राफिक
स्टोरेज इसकी भी ठीक है तानिया ओके काशिम
डट लिस्टिंग प मैलवेयर एनालिसिस अरे मेल
एनालिसिस तो अलग ही हो गया ना यार वो मग
बाउटी में कहां ले रहे उसको बग बाउटी में
तो छोड़ ही दो ना की अलग
है जेडटी ठीक
है इनसिक्योर डिसेंट्रलाइजेशन ठीक है स
साइड िटीज बॉब शूट को ढूंढते हुए चार दिन
हो गए अरे भाई क्या तुम बब शूट कि टेंशन
ले रहे हो इतनी दिया हुआ है मैंने बॉब शूट
ऑलरेडी तुम्हें तुम लोगों
को एप्लीकेशन पे जाओ ना डिफर अकेडमी के
एप्लीकेशन प जाओ ₹10 वाली जो कोर्स है
उसमें बॉब शूट दिया हुआ है
मैंने सर ऐसा कोई तरीका बता दो कि सोशल
मीडिया से मनी अर्न कर सके प्लीज बहुत
मुश्किल है यार फ्रीलांसिंग कर लो अलग-अलग
तरीके से एफिलिएट मार्केटिंग कर लो
एक लो एक ग्रुप बनाओ मतलब ग्रुपिंग कुछ
लोग होने चाहिए वहां पर जेनन काम करो पैसा
बन सकता है बट थोड़ा टाइम लगेगा या तो
ब्लॉगिंग कर लो अगर आपको चाहिए तो
ब्लॉगिंग ब्लॉगस लिख सकते हो तो ब्लॉगिंग
करो रैंक अगर होने लगी अच्छी खासी ब्लॉगस
ट्रेंडिंग टॉपिक्स
प 60 लाइक नहीं है भाई यार लाइक्स जो है
ना 187 लाइक है 200 लाइक हो जाएंगे क्या
अभी 200 लाइक 200 लाइक्स हो जाएंगे 120
187 है लाइक्स अभी
ठीक है चलिए तो यहां बातें हो गई आपके
कहने से बातें हमने कर ली एंड आपसे एक
रिक्वेस्ट है
से वहां सिर्फ बग बाउंटीज के बारे में बात
कीजिए साइबर सिक्योरिटी के बारे में बात
कीजिए ठीक
है क्या था दीपक आपका क्वेश्चन मैंने देखा
नहीं या दीपक कहीं ऊपर तो दीपक क्वेश्चन
ही नहीं दिख रहा
आपका आपका वो वाला फेस और यह वाला सेम है
हां भाई सब सेम
है चलो ठीक है गाइस थैंक यू सो मच आज के
सेशन के सेशन में जवाइन करने के लिए सर ओस
टॉप 10 में जो जो है वो सब कराना ठीक है
मैं सब करा दूंगा टेंशन नहीं लेने का ठीक
है सब करा दूंगा मैं क्यूटनेस ओवरलोडेड
क्या बात है मस्का मार रहा है ये
तो जीरो लेवल प हूं एथिकल हैकिंग में डीसी
जीएसपी से स्टार्ट कर सकता हूं बिल्कुल यू
कैन स्टार्ट विद डीसी जीएसपी डीसी जीएसपी
इज फॉर बिगनर्स टू इंटरमीडिएट एट एडवांस
लेवल
आई नो
आपसे आप उर्दू नहीं हां हां भाई हां भाई
हिंदी में लिख
दो एपीआई कीज अगर कहीं मिल रही है तो
ट्राई करो उस वो एपीआई की जिस लेवल ऑफ
परमिशन के साथ आती है उसको एक्सप्लोइट
करने की ठीक है आपका फिर वह इंपैक्ट होगा
वहां पर तभी वो वैलिड होगा सिर्फ रिपोर्ट
कर दोगे तो कोई फायदा नहीं
उसे थैंक यू सो मच फॉर अमेजिंग कंटेंट
थैंक यू सेफ नेट वेलकम
ब्रदर कर दो कर दो कोई बात नहीं रिति कर
लो लव फ्रॉम पाकिस्तान लव फ्रॉम इंडिया
ब्रदर अ चलिए ओके सो भैया और सभी लोग
जितने भी यहां पे प्रेजेंट है हमारे साथ
आज के क्लास में धन्यवाद आप सबका मिलते
हैं नेक्स्ट लाइव सेशन में एक नई वनबिल के
साथ नई धमाकेदार सीरीज के साथ सेक्शन सेशन
के साथ आई होप कि आप उसमें भी 100 प्लस
रहेंगे एंड हमारी इस जर्नी को कंटिन्यू
रखेंगे ठीक है तो धन्यवाद भाई चलते हैं
मिलते हैं ने सेशन में सभी को गुड नाइट
टाटा बाय बाय एंड हैव अ गुड हैव अ गुड
स्लीप और लाइक ठोक के जाना